WELCOME BACK TO SUB.
FOR SINCE WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
WE'RE GONNA START.
WITH.
THE IDEA FIRST ITEM TO BE HEARD
WHICH IS -- REGARDING THE OFFICE
OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
STATEWIDE INSURANCE POOL MR
FOUNTAIN I KNOW YOU'RE HERE --
BUT IF YOU WANT TO WAIT AND HAVE
A QUORUM HERE WITH SOME OF OUR
OTHER COLLEAGUES.
OKAY.
OKAY SO THAT THAN OTHERS CAN
HAVE THE BENEFIT OF HEARING YOU
AS WELL.
SO WHY DON'T WE START WITH
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
STATEWIDE TRAVEL OFFICE
TRANSACTION FEE TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT [inaudible]
WELCOME
.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR -- GEN
FILLS -- THAT DIRECTOR FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES WE
HAVE -- SEVERAL ITEMS BEFORE YOU
TODAY AND I APOLOGIZE IN ADVANCE
GO WILL BE SWAPPING OUT STAFF --
HERE AND THERE A BIT FOR THE
DIFFERENT ITEMS WE WILL.
REQUEST START WITH ISSUE NUMBER
TO THE STATE I TRAVEL OFFICE THE
TRANSACTIONAL FEE TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT.
THIS BCP IS ACTUALLY OF A BROAD
TECHNICAL BCP THAT INCLUDES --
FOUR DISTINCT COMPONENTS THE
FIRST IS -- SIX BECAUSE
CONVERSION OF SIX POINT A
POSITION SO AUTHORIZED POSITIONS
ACROSS THE DEPARTMENT TWENTY
THREE POSITIONS FOR THE
CONTRACTED FISCAL SERVICES
PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES
ACCOUNTING SERVICES TO SEVERAL
STATE DEPARTMENTS. ELEVEN
POSITIONS FOR ADMIN DIVISION --
WHICH IS AGAIN CUT --
TRANSITIONING THOSE BLANCA
POSITIONS PERMIT POSITIONS AND
THEN THE FOURTH ITEM WHICH I
THINK IS THE ONE PROBABLY MOST
IN NEED OF DISCUSSION TODAY.
IT IS AN INCREASE IN EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION SERVICE REVOLVING FUND
TO OFFSET TRANSACTION FEES ON
THE STATE WIDE TRAVEL PROGRAM --
QUICK BACKGROUND THE STATEWIDE
TRAVEL PROGRAM IS CREATED TO
SERVE AS KIND OF A SINGLE POINT
OF CONTACT FOR ALL STATE TRAVEL
BOOKING SUTRI ECONOMIES OF SCALE --
WHEN THE PROGRAM WAS INITIALLY
ESTABLISHED -- DEPARTMENTS HAD
TRANSACTION FEES EVERY TIME THEY
BOOKED A RENTAL CAR HOTEL ROOM
OR FLIGHT -- THE IDEA WAS OVER
TIME WE WOULD GAIN REVENUE FROM
OUR CONTACT THE TRAVEL VENDORS
TO BE ABLE TO OFFSET THE
TRANSACTION FEES WITH THAT
REVENUE.
SO THE REQUEST BEFORE YOU TODAY
IS AN INCREASE IN AUTHORITY SO
THAT WE CAN USE THE FUNDS WE'VE
BEEN -- WE'VE BEEN RECEIVING
FROM OUR TRAVEL PARTNERS TO
OFFSET THE TRANSACTION FEES FOR
RENTAL CARS AND HOTELS.
WITH THAT WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE AND I
BRENT JAMISON WITH ME WITH IS
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF OUR INTER
AGENCY SERVICES DIVISION WHO
OVERSEE THE STATE WHAT TRAVEL
PROGRAM.
OKAY I THINK THIS IS THE ITEM
THAT IS STILL KIND OF MAKING.
PROGRESS THE PROGRESS IS BEING
MADE SO.
UP UNLESS IF THERE RE QUESTIONS
FROM ANY OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WILL.
WILL GO -- TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
UNLESS IF THERE'S SOMETHING
YOU'D LIKE TO SAY NO NOT AT ALL
THANK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS RENE PARADISE HERE
YOU CALIFORNIA -- THE THE
ANALYSIS DOES NOTE THAT WE HAD A
REQUEST WE THINK IT'S GREATTHAT
THE STATE USES ITS PURCHASING
POWER -- TO GET DISCOUNTS WE
ALSO THINK THAT THERE'S ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO USE THAT POWER TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
WE HAVE QUALITY JOBS IN THE
STATE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE OF
THAT SO CONTRACTORS ARE
PROVIDING.
GOOD JOBS AND WE ARE WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OR HOPEFULLY
WE'LL GET SOME MORE SOON ON A ON
A POLICY WHERE MEMBERS UP.
HERE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT THEIR
EXPERIENCES WORKERS AT AIRPORTS
THANK YOU -- GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS BRYAN VASQUEZ I WORK AT
A AS A FOLK INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORT.
I WORK FOR A TRANSLATE AVIATION
SERVICES.
HI PUSH WHEELCHAIRS AND I I
HANDLE BAGS -- I WORK FOR
ALASKAN SOUTHWEST AIRLINES --
I'M JUST HERE BECAUSE MY
BROTHERS AND SISTERS AT LAX --
THEIR BUSINESS AND THEIR WORK
WAS UNDERCUT BY A COMPANY WHO
DOESN'T DO UNIONS.
SO THEIR BENEFITS WERE CUT LIKE --
HEALTH INSURANCE -- UNION.
RIGHTS AND EVERYTHING -- AND I'M
JUST HERE TO SAY THAT A EFFORT
TAXPAYERS ARE BEEN IN USE FOR
THIS STATEWIDE TRAVEL PLAN.
THEN WE DESERVE TO HAVE A SAY
AND GETTING BETTER BENEFITS LIKE
UNION RIGHTS AND HEALTH CARE AND
MORE WITH -- HIGHER WAGES TO
ACCOMMODATE THE HIGHER COST OF
LIVING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
AND THANKS FOR THE BREVITY
APPRECIATED.
MY NAME IS ALSO ALTHOUGH AT THIS
MONTH I WORK FOR JET STREAM AT
THE CABIN CLEANER AT LAX.
EVER SINCE GESTURING TOOK OVER
THE CABIN CLEANING WORK OUR JOBS
HAVE GOTTEN MUCH WORSE.
WILL WORK.
YOU ARE OVERWORKED JOBS REQUIRED
TO PEOPLE DOING IT NOW ONLY HAVE
ONE PERSON DOING A GUEST ROOM
MANAGEMENT.
ASKED ME TO DO.
WORK ABOVE MY JOB PASSED AND
THEY PROMISED TO PAY ME AT A
HIGHER RATE.
I DID A FOR MANY MONTHS BUT JUST
DREAM NEVER PAID THE THE HIGHER
RATE.
WE HAD A UNION BEFORE WE WERE
TREATED BETTER AND PAY CORRECTLY
FOR OUR WORK WHEN WE HAD A UNION
I'M HERE TO SAY TO YOU THAT WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT THE OUR
STATE TRAVEL PROGRAM LIKE ANY
OTHER.
THAT SPENDS MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS DOLLARS.
HELPS OF HOLD STANDARD FOR
CALIFORNIA WORKERS.
AIRLINES AND THEIR CONTRACTORS
WHO BENEFIT DIRECTLY FROM THE
STATE.
TRAVEL PROGRAM WAS DUE MORE TO
COMPLY WITH OUR LOSS.
SUPPORT GOOD IAN AND JOBS AND
ENSURE THE SAFETY OF ALL WORKERS
AND PASSENGERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND AND I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU
TAKEN TIME TO TRAVEL AND COME UP
HERE AND JOIN US BUT WHAT I'M
GONNA ASK IS.
SINCE YOU ALREADY DID TO GERMAN
ALREADY HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK -- WHAT AND YOU CAN PLEASE
BE SEATED UP WHAT I WHAT I'LL
ASK IS IF THE WHOEVER ELSE IS
GOING TO BE SPEAKING TO JUST
KEEP IT TO YOUR NAME -- THE
PLACE THAT YOU'RE WORKING AN
AFFILIATION AND ME TO COMMENT IF
YOU'D LIKE.
JUST FOR THE SAKE OF BREVITY SO
IF ANYBODY ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK.
HI MY NAME IS BARBARA GOMES I
ALSO WORK FOR ANY X. -- I'M
EMPLOYER -- DOES SHE MUSCLE.
ALONG HERE ALSO IF THE AXE --
THE SAY.
IF YOU CAN JUST GIVE ONE
SENTENCE PLEASE.
I'M HERE TO SAY TO YOU THAT WE
NEED. TO BE IN SHORT STAY TRAVEL
PROGRAM.
ALL OF ANY PROGRAM THAT SPEND
MILLIONS A CALIFORNIA TAXPAYER
DOLLARS HELP -- STANDARDS THE
CALIFORNIA WORKERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
IF YOU CAN BE BRIEF AND JUST
KEEP IT TO ONE OR TWO SENTENCES
PLEASE THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MARK ON SALAS AND
I WORK AS A WHEELCHAIR
ASSISTANCE WHERE.
THEY ASKED ME TO PUT PUSH WITH
TWO WHEEL CHAIRS AT THE SAME
TIME WHICH BIOLAGE.
AIRPORT POLICIES AND IT'S UNFAIR
WHERE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE.
IN CAUGHT DOING THAT HAVE GONE
AND FIGHTER FOR NO REASON AND
SINCE WE DON'T HAVE [inaudible]
ENOUGH STAFFS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
GLORIA ROMERO I WORKED AT THE LA
X. FOR TWELVE YEARS AND I WORKED
AS A UNION FOR TWELVE YEARS BUT
SINCE SOUTH WAS HIRED AS A YES
WE NO LONGER UNION NICE --
WORKERS AND WE ARE ASKING FOR
THE FOR YOU GUYS TO HELP US WITH
THAT AND BECAUSE IT OUR UNION
BACK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE SHE HAD IT.
THIS ITEM IS GOING TO BE HELD
OPEN SO LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT ITEM.
THANK YOU CHAIR -- ISSUE
REGULATORY WHENEVER EXTRA
TRAILER BILL.
JEEZ OR GONNA HAVE A FEW FOLKS
SWAP OUT CHAIRS HERE -- THIS IS
ACTUALLY -- THREE DISTINCT
PIECES OF TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE --
FOR THE FIRST ONE I'LL BRIEFLY
ENTERED UP TO SIT AND MISS
LOOKING BUILT ON THE PART OF
FINANCE WILL BE SITTING IN.
THE SECOND ONE IS A DEPARTMENT
FINANCES LANGUAGE SO WE'LL LET
THEM PERCENT ON THAT IF THAT'S
OKAY.
AND THE THIRD PIECE IS RELATED
TO THE ANNEX AND MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER KENNY WHICH IS THAT DOWN
TO MY RIGHT WILL INTRODUCE THAT
PSA IF YOU DON'T MIND ME
STOPPING YOU FOR A MINUTE I
FORGOT THAT I NEED TO ASK LA OR
CO IF THE IF.
OF THE PLEDGE COUNCIL HE NEEDED
TO MAKE A COMMENT FOR THE
PREVIOUS -- ITEM.
WELL BRIAN BROWN AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
REVIEW TO BE KEEPING WE DON'T
HAVE ANY CONCERNS OKAY.
OKAY THANK YOU -- SO THE FIRST
TEASER TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE --
MAKE SOME CHANGES TO THE
MINISTRATION OF THE GOLDEN STATE
FINANCIAL MARKET PLACE
PROGRAMMER GS MARK -- WE ARE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE ON DRAFT
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE JUST THIS --
PROGRAM ESSENTIALLY ALLOWS --
BOTH APARTMENTS AND LOCAL
ENTITIES TO BORROW MONEY WHEN
THEY'RE MAKING LARGE PURCHASES A
LOT COMPETITIVE INTEREST RATES
THAT DOESN'T HAVE THE BUDGET ALL
AT ONCE.
IT'S BEEN AROUND SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY SIX IN THE STATUE HASN'T
BEEN UPDATED IN SEVERAL YEARS
AND GIVEN THE EVER CHANGING
NATURE THE BOND FINANCING MARKET --
WE'RE WORKING TOGETHER TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT LANGUAGE IS UP TO
DATE MEETS THE NEEDS OF THE
STATE [inaudible]
THANK.
GOOD AFTERNOON SALLY LOOKING
BILL DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- SO
THE SECOND TRAILER BILL PROPOSAL
IN YOUR GENDER IS RELATED TO
GOVERNMENT CODE -- FIFTEEN EIGHT
OH FIVE THIS PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL CORRECTS A DRAFTING ERROR
IN SIX SECTION FIFTEEN IT'LL
FIVE THE GOVERNMENT CODE THAT
WAS ADDED BY SEX BY CHAPTER --
SEVEN FIFTY FIVE STATS OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THAT MEETS
YOU DON'T PUBLIC BUILDING
SUBJECT TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
OVERSIGHT FOR THE INSTALLATION
OR EXEMPTION OF THE BABY DIAPER
CHANGING STATION REQUIREMENTS.
UNDER CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
THE STATE A SOVEREIGN AND STATE
FACILITIES ARE NOT SUBJECT TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
EXCUSE ME NOT SUBJECT TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTAL PERMIT OR OVERSIGHT
REQUIREMENTS AND THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD HAVE THE APPROPRIATELY
HAVE THE STATE PUBLIC WORKS
BOARD AS THE ENTITY PROVIDING
THOSE NOTES BUT NECESSARY
OVERSIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY.
JASON KENNEY -- DEPARTMENTS ALL
SERVICES THE THIRD TRAVEL
LANGUAGE IS A AN EXEMPTION IN --
BUILDING CODE -- THAT WOULD --
PREVENTIVE BOTH THE CAPITAL
ANNEX PROJECT IN THE CURRENT
SPRING SPACE BUILDING FROM
OCCURRING SIGNIFICANT COSTS
RELATED -- TO HIGHWAY PATROL
BEING IN THE BUILDING -- THEY
HAVE A MODICUM OF SPACE IN THOSE
BUILDINGS THAT WOULD NEED TO BE
BUILT TO ESSENTIALLY DIFFERENT
STANDARDS THAT WOULD RIPPLE
THROUGHOUT THE BUILDINGS -- AND
INCREASE THE COST SIGNIFICANTLY
THIS WOULD ALLOW US TO PROCEED
WITH CONSTRUCTION WITHOUT --
NEEDING -- TO BILL TO THOSE
EXCESSIVELY HIGHER STANDARDS
[inaudible]
THE COMMENTS [inaudible]
GREAT.
SINCE WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM --
THIS IS A ITEM THAT'S GOING TO
BE VOTED ON BUT WE WILL HOLD IT.
UNTIL THE TIME WE HAVE A QUORUM
ESTABLISHED AND IF THIS WOULD BE
A GOOD OPPORTUNITY TO REMIND
COLLEAGUES THAT SERVE ON THE
COMMITTEE -- TO UP PLEASE --
ARRIVE SO THAT WE CAN AT LEAST
ESTABLISH QUORUM AND WE CAN GET
THE VOTING ON THE WAY.
AND WE CAN ALWAYS ADD ON LATER
ON THANK YOU [inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT.
PUBLIC COMING FOR THIS OKAY.
GREAT.
RIGHT NEXT ITEM.
WELL I'M SORRY QUESTION FROM THE
MEMBERS OBVIOUSLY NOT -- ISSUE
ITEM FOR SACRAMENTO REGION STATE
PROPERTY IMPROVEMENTS -- JASON
KENNEY AGAIN SO THERE ARE THREE
PROJECTS THAT ARE GROUPED
TOGETHER HERE -- TAKEN SLIGHTLY
OUT OF ORDER BECAUSE PERSPECTIVE --
UP WITH CONSISTENCY LOGIC -- THE
THUS MIDDLE WHEN THERE IS TWENTY
MILLION WE'RE ASKING FOR IN
GENERAL FUND FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION PHASE OF THE STATE
THE STATE PRINT PLANT -- THAT IS
A SIXTY FIVE YEAR OLD BUILDING
THAT IS GROSSLY OVERSIZE FAILING
FOUNDATIONS FAILING -- HAS
SIGNIFICANT -- REMEDIATION
ISSUES ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND TONS OF DIRT -- NEEDS
TO BE REMOVED AND REMEDIATED THE
THE THE LEAD TO CONCENTRATION
SITES A HUNDRED TIMES -- SAFE
LIMITS -- ITSELF -- NEED TO BE
DEMOLISHED THAT LEADS TO THE
FIRST -- BUILDING LISTED THERE
WERE ASKING -- FOR ONE BILLION
IN LEASE FROM THE BOND FINANCING
FOR THE DESIGN BUILD PHASE OF
THE RICHEST BILL OF OUR PROJECT
BOTH OF THESE PROJECTS I JUST
MENTIONED WERE POP.
AUTHORIZED -- WE ARE LOOKING TO
CONSTRUCT OUR THIRD AND FINAL
HIGH RISE BUILDING IN SACRAMENTO
THIS WOULD ALLOW US TO ADDRESS
NOT ONLY OUR LONG TERM SPACE
PLANNING NEEDS.
BUT ALSO -- IN PRODUCTION
EFFICIENCIES IN SACRAMENTO
RELATED TO DIGEST BUILDINGS.
AND FINALLY.
PRESSING FOR A TWENTY MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND FOR THE PERFORMANCE
CRITERIA OF THE RENOVATION OF
THE OLD RESOURCES BUILDING --
THIS IS TGS IS MOST DEFICIENT A
BUILDING AN ARK FIFTY EIGHT
BUILDING PORTFOLIO -- IT HAS THE
NEED FOR ENTIRELY NEW BUILDING
SYSTEMS MECHANICAL ELECTRICAL
PLUMBING -- I. T. A. B. -- IT
HAS SIGNIFICANT FIRE LIFE SAFETY
ISSUES INCLUDING NOT BEING SPENT
THIRD AND EFFICIENT EXITING
STAIRS IT ALSO A SEISMIC
DEFICIENCIES HAZMAT AND IS NOT
ADA COMPLIANT.
GREAT TO SEE THE PROGRESS THAT'S
BEING MADE THANK YOU SIR
[inaudible]
FINANCE AVAIL.
SURE -- WE RECOMMEND APPROVAL
THESE PROPOSALS WE KNOW THAT THE
FIRST TWO PROJECTS ARE
CONTINUATIONS OF THE NEXT PHASE
OF FINANCING FOR PROJECTS THAT
WERE PREVIOUSLY APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
IN THE NEW PRODUCT THAT THEIR
PROJECT WILL NEW AS THE
DEPARTMENT NOTED -- THEY
RESOURCES BUILDING IS IDENTIFIED
AS THE MOST EFFICIENT SACRAMENTO
AREA BUILDING SO RENOVATION IS
CERTAINLY WARRANTED.
THANK YOU.
COMMENTS FROM A COMMITTEE.
NO PUBLIC COMMENTS.
GREAT MOVING ON AT THIS ITEM.
IS TO BE VOTED ON BUT WILL VOTE
WHEN WE HAVE QUORUM.
HOPEFULLY THAT SERVES AS A
REMINDER TO OUR COLLEAGUES.
ISSUE ITEM NUMBER FIVE DISASTER --
THE I'M SORRY DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU CHAIR AS A STAFF COME
UP AND JOIN ME THIS ITEM WAS
ADDED TO THE AGENDA WE DON'T
HAVE A BUDGET ASK TIED TO THIS
ITEM BUT WE DID WANT.
TO PROVIDE INFORMATION UPDATE AT
COMMITTEE STAFFS REQUESTS ON THE
DVD PROGRAM WITH ME TODAY I HAVE
TO MEMBERS OF OUR TEAM MATT
BENDERS OUR ASSISTANT AT THE FOR
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS AND ANGEL
SHELVES ARE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE PROCUREMENT DIVISION --
THANKS MATT BENDER FROM DG US --
BRIEFLY THE STATE'S DVB PROGRAM
WHICH IS ADMINISTERED BY TGS
OFFERS A VARIETY OF BENEFITS TO
COMPANIES -- THAT ARE OWNED BY
DISABLED VETERANS THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN.
CONTRACTS WITH THE STATE
GOVERNMENT CONTRACT WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CONTRACTS WITH
UTILITY COMPANIES -- STATES GOAL
IS TO HAVE 3% OF ITS TOTAL
CONTRACTING DOLLARS GO TO TV'S
EITHER AS PRIME CONTRACTORS OR
SUBCONTRACTORS -- THE STATE IS
MEET.
AT THAT 3% GOAL OVERALL FOR THE
LAST NINE YEARS -- THAT INCLUDES
PRELIMINARY DATA. FOR TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTEEN WHICH WERE STILL
FINALIZING BUT WHICH INDICATES.
A DVB PARTICIPATION RATE OF
ROUGHLY FOUR POINT 4% OVERALL AT
ABOUT FOUR POINT 7% FOR THOSE
DEPARTMENTS THAT OPERATE WITHIN
DG IS.
SYSTEM OF DELEGATED PURCHASING
AUTHORITY -- PROGRAM WAS
RECENTLY AUDITED -- STATE
AUDITOR OFFERED A NUMBER
RECOMMENDATIONS -- TGS WORKING
TO RESPOND TO THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS -- AS EARLY
EXAMPLE OF THE TYPE OF RESULTS
WERE ACHIEVING WE RECENTLY
CONCLUDED -- SOLICITATION FOR
ENTERPRISE TECHNOLOGY PRODUCTS
THAT CLUED SERVERS STORAGE THAT
KIND OF DATA CENTER QUITMAN --
REPLACES A NUMBER OF EXPIRING
CONTRACTS RICHLY WORDED IN.
BETWEEN TWENTY TWELVE AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND BACK THEN. FOR MOST
OF THOSE CONTRACTS WE DECIDED TO
WAIT DVB PARTICIPATION
REQUIREMENTS.
THIS TIME WE MADE A CONCERTED
EFFORT TO DESIGN THE ARE
MAXIMIZED.
PARTICIPATION -- THAT INCLUDED
REQUIRING NINE DVP BETTORS TO
SUBCONTRACT AT LEAST 25% OF THE
ANCILLARY SERVICES LIKE THE
INSTALLATION THE WARRANTY AND
SUPPORT -- TO DVP IS AND THE
RESULTING -- AWARDS AND PROPOSED
TO WORDS -- INCLUDE -- TO DVP
PRIME CONTRACTORS WHO WANT AS
THE PRIME -- WHICH IS NOT
SOMETHING WE HAD ON THE PRIOR
CONTRACTS AND TWELVE ADDITIONAL
TV'S -- PARTICIPATING AS
SUBCONTRACTORS -- HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ELSE'S
ANGELA CHAU JUST OUT OF
CURIOSITY ARE THESE ALL
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES -- WELL
DVP IS I BELIEVE THE OF THE THE
VETERAN HAS TO BE DOMICILED IN
CALIFORNIA SO YES THESE ARE
GENERALLY.
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES I THINK
THERE'S A TECHNICAL SENSE IN
WHICH THE VETERAN COULD BE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THE BUSINESS NOT
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE
CASE WITH ANY OF THE COMPANIES
WE HAVE HERE.
THIS IS THIS IS GONNA BE A ITEM
THAT'S GOING TO BE HELD OPEN BUT
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
COMES FROM FINANCE OR LA -- DOPE
[inaudible]
GREAT [inaudible]
OF PUBLIC COMMENT [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THE DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE PROGRAM WAS ADOPTED
TO ALLOW VETERANS WHO WERE
WOUNDED WHILE PROTECTING OUR
FREEDOM.
FREEDOMS THAT WE ARE PRACTICING
HERE TODAY. TO BE ABLE TO
COMPETE FOR BUSINESS WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
VETERANS WOUNDED BY WAR HAVE
BEEN FAILED BY SYSTEMS AT ALL
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT.
TGS HAS NOW ADOPTED THAT
MENTALITY AND IS EXCLUDING.
DISABLED VETERANS FROM DOING
BUSINESS WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN STATE
AUDITOR'S.
DVP PROGRAM REPORT.
HAS HIGHLIGHTED THIS FACT AND
PRESENTED FOR SOLUTIONS TO THIS
CONCERNING MANNER.
TGS HAS IGNORED SUCH ADVICE.
AND HAS AWARDED THE I. T.
ENTERPRISE CONTRACT WHICH
FURTHER RESTRICTS DVP
PARTICIPATION.
A CLEAR SOLUTION PRESENTED IN
THE STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT.
WAS TO ALLOW DISABLED VETERAN
FIRMS THE ABILITY TO COMPETE ON
STATE CONTRACTS.
TGS HAS FAILED TO FOLLOW THE
ADVICE AND IS GONE DIRECTLY
AGAINST THE RECOMMENDATIONS.
BY NOT ALLOWING ALL THE V. FIRMS
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE I. T.
ENTERPRISE STATEWIDE CONTRACT.
THIS CALL LIMóN EIGHT THE
ABILITY 495% OF THE FIRMS IN THE
IT SPACE TO CONDUCT BUSINESS.
IN CLOSING THE DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESS COMMUNITY IS ASKING
THAT WE BE ALLOWED TO
PARTICIPATE ON THE NEWLY CREATED
IT ENTERPRISE CONTRACT.
THERE SHOULD NEVER BE AN
INSTANCE WHERE DVD FIRMS ARE
RESTRICTED FROM DOING BUSINESS
WITH THE STATE.
PLEASE TAKE THE TIME TO READ THE
SUMMARY OF THE STATE AUDITOR'S
REPORT.
THE NUMBERS ARE STAGGERING AND
FRANKLY INEXCUSABLE.
THERE'S A SIMPLE SOLUTION.
AND WE WOULD ASK YOUR HELP IN
ACCOMPLISHING OUR MISSION. TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE TAKING CARE
TAKING CARE OF OUR DISABLED
VETERANS.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND FEEL
FREE TO REACH OUT TO ME FOR MORE
INSIGHT AND HOW TO CORRECT THESE
WRONGS.
THAT HAVE BEEN COMMITTED THANK
YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARTY COLOR WITH
THE VETERANS BUSINESS SO READ
CENTER.
WE WILL WORK WITH -- VETERANS --
BOTH WORKS COMING OUT OF SERVICE
AND DOES HAVE BEEN IN BUSINESS
FOR A LONG TIME TO HELP WITH
TRAINING.
AND OTHER BUSINESS NEEDS --
WE'RE JUST UP WE PARTNER FOR
MANY YEARS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES AND WE ARE.
WE NOTE -- AS MISTER BENDER SAID
THAT THE PROGRAM IN GENERAL HAS
BEEN SUCCESSFUL AND IT'S A GREAT
WAY FOR OUR RETURNING VETERANS
TO FIND WAYS AS SUBCONTRACTORS
OR EVEN THROUGH THE CAL CARD
PROCESS -- TO GET INTO BUSINESS
A WITH THE SUPPORT OF THE STATE.
A WE WILL ALWAYS WORK WITH -- D.
G. S. ON ANY OF THE ISSUES THAT
MAY BE OF CONCERN TO OUR
INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS AND BUT WE
JUST WANT TO BE ON RECORD THAT
WE THINK THIS PROGRAM'S BEEN
VERY SUCCESSFUL.
CAN ALWAYS BE IMPROVED BUT WE
THINK DIGEST IS DONE A GREAT JOB
MANAGING THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN OF
AFRICA MARKET FOR THE UNITED
STATES RETURNS BUSINESS ALLIANCE
HER TO ECHO THE SENTIMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
A THIS AS I MENTIONED BEFORE
THIS ITEM IS GOING TO BE HELD
OPEN SEEMS LIKE THERE'S STILL
SOME WORK AND PROGRESS THAT'S
GOING TO BE MADE SO -- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU CHAIR.
NEXT ITEM ELECTRICAL ELECTRIC
VEHICLE SERVICE EQUIPMENT.
SO AGAIN IS -- WE SWAPPED A SO
SO ABOUT -- COPILOT'S HERE --
THE REQUEST BEFORE YOU IS --
ACTUALLY YOUR THREE OF OUR FIVE
YEAR -- ORIGINAL ASK -- TO
INSTALL ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING STATION INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR BOTH THOUGH WORKFORCE
CHARGING AND WORKPLACE CHARGING
ACROSS THE STATE AND FACILITIES
THIS THIRTY YEAR ASK IS A ONE
TIME REQUEST FOR EIGHTEEN POINT
SIX MILLION.
THE PERCENT OF THAT WOULD BE --
GENERAL FUND REVENUE A 50% AGAIN
WOULD BE SERVICE REVOLVING FUND --
TO CONTINUE THE GOOD WORK WE'RE
DOING ACROSS THE STATE
INSTALLING EVEY CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH ME I HAVE
NANCY ENDER WHO'S OUR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR SUSTAINABILITY AND
OVERSEES THIS PROGRAM HAPPEN
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE --
ANY QUESTIONS FROM A OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE [inaudible]
OF LA YOUR DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO.
GREAT ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS
[inaudible]
A THIS WILL BE A VOTE ITEM.
BUT ONCE WE HAVE QUORUM THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
I BELIEVE THAT -- CONCLUDES OUR
ITEMS THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR
[inaudible]
YEAH.
THANK YOU AGAIN TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
THE NEXT ITEM ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN
OFFICE OF A PLANNING AND
RESEARCH PRECISION MEDICINE.
IS NOT GOING TO BE HEARD TODAY
SO IT'S OFF THE CALENDAR -- AND
WE ARE GOING TO GO TO EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS ISSUE ITEM.
EIGHT AND SINCE THE WE HAVE A
QUORUM WHY DON'T WE TAKE A QUICK
[inaudible]
ROLL CALL [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
LACKEY.
THIS AREA PRESIDENT WICKS
[inaudible]
TANK [inaudible]
WICKS.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
I KNOW.
WHY DON'T WE JUST GO BACK AS
YOU'RE GETTING SETTLED IN TAKE
YOUR TAKE A MINUTE?
BUT WE GO BACK AND VOTE ON THE
VOTE ONLY ITEM.
SO THAT'S ITEMS -- ISSUE NUMBER
FROM ISSUE NUMBER ONE THROUGH.
TWELVE THIS IS VOTE ONLY.
THEY'RE GONNA THEY'RE GONNA GIVE
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THEIR MOTION.
SO WANT TO TALK.
I WANT TO TWELVE THIS GOOD FOR
IT.
ARE THERE ANY.
NO ONE REALLY KNEW STAND.
OKAY [inaudible]
ACTUALLY.
TO IN A STATE OF THE LOCAL.
OKAY SO I WOULD I THREE MOTIONS
ON READ THAT. TWENTY HAVE SO
HAVE SO VOTE ON THE COUNTER
MINUS THREE IN.
TEN OKAY.
THAT THE MOTION TO ITEMS ONE
THROUGH.
TWELVE OF ALL BUT ITEMS. THREE
INTENT DO I HAVE A MOTION MR
CHIU.
SECOND THANK YOU [inaudible]
NAZARIAN HI.
CHIU.
LACKEY.
WICKS THANK.
GREAT NEXT ITEM OF LET'S TO
INDIVIDUALLY BREAK IT UP --
ISSUE NUMBER THREE ISSUE ITEM.
THREE THANK YOU.
NAZARIAN.
I CHIU.
LACKEY NOT VOTED [inaudible]
WE SHOULD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LAST FROM THE VOTE ONLY ISSUE
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
TEN THEIR MOTION.
IS THERE IN HI [inaudible] TWO
LACKEY [inaudible]
WICKS TECH.
HE WANTED TO MOTIONS ON THE JET
STUFF.
SURE WHILE WE'RE AT IT LET'S GO.
TO ISSUE THREE FROM
INFRASTRUCTURE TRAILER BILL
[inaudible]
OF THEIR MOTION TO MOVE THE ITEM
WHICH MAYBE ON YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
DO I HAVE A MOTION [inaudible]
SALUTE.
THANK YOU SECOND PERFECT.
IS THERE AN EYE EXAM
[inaudible]
CHIU FIVE LACKEY I'M WICKS TANK
GOOD.
AND THE STATE PROPERTY.
FOR NEXT ON TO ISSUE FOUR
SACRAMENTO REGION STATE PROPERTY
IMPROVEMENTS.
DO I HAVE A MOTION.
IS THERE AN THEIR SECOND A SITE.
SURE THANK YOU.
ALL GOD TO BE HERE IS THERE IT
IS AND I Q. [inaudible]
LACKEY.
AND ONE MORE ELECTRIC VEHICLE.
ISSUE NUMBER SIX ELECTRICAL
VEHICLE ELECTRIC VEHICLE SERVICE
EQUIPMENT SIR.
THANK YOU SIR SECOND
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IS THERE AN ACT NUMBER.
SIX ELECTRIC VEHICLE SERVICE
EQUIPMENT [inaudible]
CHIU HI [inaudible]
MR SACK.
NOT LOADED OKAY.
AND THEN WEEKS AND TING
[inaudible]
REALLY GREAT -- JUDICIARY AND
SINCE WE HAVE ALL OF YOU HERE OF
WE'LL START WITH YOUR
PRESENTATION BUT THEN.
AFTER THIS WILL GO BACK TO ITEM
NUMBER. ONE FOR MR FOUNTAIN TO
COME UP AND MAKE HIS
PRESENTATION.
RIGHT THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK
YOU READY TO HEAD AGAIN.
WELL THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY MY NAME'S KAREN
BAKER AND I'M THE CHIEF SERVICE
OFFICER FOR CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS OFFICE OF THE
GOVERNOR.
I'M HERE TO DISCUSS THE
GOVERNOR'S CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS CAMPAIGN
FUNDED THROUGH AB SEVENTY TWO
AND SPECIFICALLY CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS ROLE.
BEFORE DIVING INTO THE DETAILS
OF THE CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS FINDING I
WONDER FIRST CLARIFIED.
THAT IN TOTAL FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS WAS AWARDED FOR THIS
EFFORT.
WITH THIRTY MILLION BEING
ADMINISTERED BY OUR AGENCY.
I ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY FOR THEIR SWIFT
APPROVAL OF AB.
SEVENTY TWO AS WE BELIEVE IT CAN
MAKE A SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE BY
IMPACTING AT LEAST ONE MILLION
OF THE MOST DISASTER AND
SOCIALLY VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
I THINK AS YOU KNOW GOVERNOR
NEWSOME IS COMMITTED TO TACKLING
ISSUES OF CLIMATE CHANGE HAD ON
WHILE THE GOVERNOR VALUES DATA
ON ENVIRONMENTAL HAZARDS HE
BELIEVES OUR STRATEGY FOR
PREPAREDNESS.
NEEDS TO BE INFORMED BY QUOTE
SOCIAL VULNERABILITY FACTORS
INCLUDING SOCIALIZE ISOLATION
POVERTY.
LANGUAGE BARRIERS AND OTHER
ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS TO
CHALLENGES.
THAT IS WHY THE CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
CAMPAIGN IS A CRUCIAL PILLAR OF
THIS DISASTER FINDING.
I'D LIKE TO PROVIDE SOME
CAMPAIGN DETAILS.
THE CALIFORNIA FOR ALL EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS CAMPAIGN WILL
LEVERAGE THIRTY MILLION OF AB
SEVENTY TWO FUNDING TO BUILD
RESILIENCY AMONG VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS IN UNDER RESOURCE
AREAS.
AT THE HIGHEST RISK FOR NATURAL
DISASTERS IT WILL CONNECT
CALIFORNIANS TO PREPAREDNESS AND
RESPONSE EFFORTS THROUGH THREE
PRIMARY STREAMS.
THE FIRST ONE WILL BE TWENTY
FOUR MILLION.
POINT TWO FIVE WHICH WILL BE
GRANTED TO EMPOWER CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
CBO'S TO PROVIDE EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS EDUCATION AND
RESOURCES.
WELL HELLO YES WILL BE
ADMINISTERING A MAJORITY OF
THESE FUNDS CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE EXPANSION OF THESE STYLES.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WHO MAY NOT
BE FAMILIAR WITH LEAST US IT'S A
PROGRAM THAT WAS STARTED IN
SANTA BARBARA.
AS AN EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
TRAINING FOCUSED ON GETTING
SPANISH SPEAKING FAMILIES
PREPARED IN A CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY MEANINGFUL FORMAT.
THIS FUNDING WILL FUNDING WILL
ALLOW US TO DOUBLE THE STILLS
FOOTPRINT BY INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF PROGRAMS FROM THIRTY
TO SIXTY THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WELL AS WALL ALSO TRANSLATING
THE CURRENT CONTENT INTO
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGES.
THE SECOND STREAM WILL BE TWELVE
POINT SIX MILLION WHICH WILL
PROVIDE COMMUNITY GRANTS TO BOTH
CITIZEN EMERGENCY RESPONSE TEAMS
ALSO KNOWN AS CERT.
AS WELL AS FUND TO CALIFORNIA
FOR ALL AMERICORPS DISASTER
TEAMS.
AND THE FINAL THIRTEEN POINT ONE
FIVE MILLION WILL FIND A PUBLIC
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN THAT ENGAGES
THE MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS RESOURCES.
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL WEEKS WE
WILL BE RELEASING REQUEST FOR
APPLICATIONS AND PROPOSALS FOR
EACH OF THE ABOVE MENTIONED
COMPONENTS.
ALL RELEASE STATES WILL BE
AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE IT
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS DOT GOD.
MAKING IT ACCESSIBLE TO ALL OF
YOU IN YOUR CONSTITUENTS ICAN
NOW ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
THANK YOU SURE.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS [inaudible]
OKAY.
FINANCE NOPE WE ALREADY.
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY -- TO VOTE
ON THIS UP FOR NOW THIS WILL BE
HELD OPEN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
MUCH. TO RESERVE A COMMENT.
CAN WE DO.
WE'RE GOING TO AMERICA FOR IT
THAT'S RIGHT [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THE BILL.
AND WHEN THEY DO THAT RIGHT NOW.
WE CAN RUN IF YOU DON'T MIND
GIVING US A MINUTE WHY DON'T WE
CENTURY HAVE MISS WHICH JOINING
US RIGHT NOW WHY DON'T WE GO
AHEAD AND ADD HER ON TO SOME OF
THE VOTES THAT WE HAVE.
OF ITEMS WERE VOTE ONLY -- THE
FIRST ONE WAS EVERYTHING AT THE
FIRST MOTION WAS FOR ALL ALL
ITEMS.
IN THE VOTE ONLY SECTION
EXCLUDING ITEMS THREE AND TEN
THIS WEEK SAID HE VOTE.
SECOND MOTION WAS -- ONLY ITEM
NUMBER.
THREE THIRD MOTION WAS ITEM ONLY
ITEM NUMBER TEN FROM THE VOTE
ONLY THANK YOU.
NUMBER.
ISSUE.
THREE FROM THE ISSUES BEING
HEARD -- ISSUE ITEM THREE
INFRASTRUCTURE TRAILER BILL.
ISSUE NUMBER FOR SACRAMENTO
REGION STATE PROPERTY
IMPROVEMENTS.
ISSUE NUMBER SIX ELECTRIC
VEHICLE.
SERVICE EQUIPMENT [inaudible]
THE CARD.
RIGHT YOU'RE ALL GOOD
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ISSUE ITEM NUMBER NINE
AMERICORPS EXPANSION
[inaudible]
RIGHT -- IF IT'S POSSIBLE IF I
COULD HAVE SHEILA BOXLEY JOIN ME
FOR SOME COMMENTARY SHE'LL BE --
SHE'S THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
THE CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION
CENTER ONE OF OUR GRANTEES.
POSSIBLE.
PLEASE GREAT THANKS.
SOME ALSO YOUR TODAY TO
HIGHLIGHT ASPECTS OF THE
PROPOSED INCREASE IN CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS AMERICORPS FINDING.
I'M JOINED BY SHEILA BOXLEY THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE CHILD
ABUSE PREVENTION CENTER AND ONE
OF CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS
GRANTEES.
IN A MOMENT SHE'LL BE ABLE TO
SHARE FIRST HAND HER INSIGHTS ON
WHAT IT MEANS TO REALLY UTILIZE
AMERICORPS MEMBERS WELL I DRESS
BUT BEFORE THAT I'D LIKE TO
OFFER A GLIMPSE INTO AMERICORPS
CALIFORNIA. FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
DON'T KNOW AMERICORPS IS A
FEDERAL FUNDING SOURCE THAT USES
THE POWER OF SERVICE TO ADDRESS
LOCAL COMMUNITY NEEDS.
OUR STATE COMMISSION CURRENTLY
OVERSEES FIVE THOUSAND
AMERICORPS MEMBERS SLOTS THAT
ARE PLACED WITH SIXTY GRANTEES.
OVER 50% OF THE FUNDING REQUIRED
TO RUN THESE PROGRAMS COMES FROM
A LOCAL MATCH SOURCE.
WHICH TYPICALLY COMES FROM A
LARGE CORPORATION A FOUNDATION.
OR PERHAPS OTHER PUBLIC FUNDS.
GOVERNOR NEWSOME UNDERSTANDS
THAT THERE ARE MANY HIGH NEED
COMMUNITIES THAT SIMPLY ARE NOT
IN A POSITION TO SECURE THIS
MATCH
AND THEREFORE THEY FIND
THEMSELVES UNABLE TO APPLY.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE PROPOSING AND
INVESTMENT OF STATE FUNDS IN
THIS CASE TEN OF THE TWENTY
MILLION. TO GROW AMERICORPS IN
THESE HIGH NEED COMMUNITIES.
ALSO AS MANY AS YOU MAY KNOW
UPON THE COMPLETION OF A FULL
YEAR OF FULL TIME SERVICE AN
AMERICORPS MEMBER RECEIVE SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS. TO PAY BACK
STUDENT LOANS OR TO INVEST IN
FUTURE STUDIES OR TRAINING.
THE GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED AN
INCREASE OF THIS AWARD TO REACH
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER FULL
TIME MEMBER.
WITHIN INVESTMENT TOTAL OF TEN
MILLION.
THE AVERAGE CALIFORNIA'S STUDENT
DEBT IS THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
PER PERSON.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT ONE WAY TO
PAY DOWN A PORTION OF THIS DEBT.
IS TO ASSIST THOSE WHO ARE
WILLING TO GIVE A YEAR OF THEIR
LIFE IN SERVICE TO HIGH NEED
CALIFORNIANS.
WE BELIEVE THAT WHILE SACRAMENTO
HAS BENEFITED FROM STRONG
AMERICORPS PROGRAMS LIKE BIRTH
IN BEYOND WHERE MEMBERS TEACH
PARENTING SKILLS TO LOW INCOME
FAMILIES.
ALL HIGH NEED COMMUNITIES
DESERVE THIS PROGRAM.
WHILE CITY YOUR LOS ANGELES
MEMBERS GIVE INVALUABLE SUPPORT
TO YOUNG PEOPLE IN ORDER TO
CLOSE THE ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT
GAP.
AGAIN ALL STRUGGLING COMMUNITIES
DESERVE THESE PROGRAMS.
WE HAVE AMERICORPS MEMBERS
PROVIDING SERVICES FOR VETS FOR
THE HOMELESS FOR FOSTER YOU.
AS WELL AS MEMBERS ENGAGED IN MY
BUYER MIDDLE STEWARDSHIP AND
HELPING LOW INCOME FAMILIES
NAVIGATE THE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
I MEAN THAT SHOULD BE ACCESSIBLE
TO ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
IN THE END AMERICORPS MEETS
COMMUNITY NEEDS BY ADDING
CAPACITY TO THE ORGANIZATIONS
WHO ARE ON THE GROUND.
DOING THE HARD WORK DAY IN AND
DAY OUT WHAT WE'VE LEARNED IS
THAT AMERICORPS MEMBERS TAKE
THEIR EXPERIENCE AND BECOME A
PART OF THE NONPROFIT AND PUBLIC
SECTOR WORK FORCE.
OR WORK IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
WITH A VIBRANT COMMITMENT TO
VOLUNTEERING.
AND IT ACTUALLY SAVES TAXPAYER
DOLLARS BY PROVIDING EFFICIENT
SOLUTIONS TO SOME OF OUR MOST
CHALLENGING PUBLIC NEEDS.
BUT ABOVE ALL AMERICORPS UNITES
CALIFORNIANS IN SERVICE AS MANY
VETERANS WILL TELL YOU.
ALTHOUGH THE SERVICEMAN OR WOMAN
STANDING NEXT TO YOU MAY LOOK
DIFFERENT FROM YOU ARE COME FROM
A DIFFERENT BACKGROUND.
SERVING TOGETHER CONNECTS YOU IN
A TRULY FUNDAMENTAL WAY.
AND IN THE DAY AND AGE WHERE OUR
SOCIETY IS BECOMING MORE AND
MORE FRACTURED WE ARE CALLED TO
INVEST IN OPPORTUNITIES TO BRING
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES US STRONGER
THAT'S WHAT UNITES US AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS
ARE REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY THANK YOU AND IF WE
CAN.
BRIEFLY TOUCH UPON SOME OF THE
ITEMS THAT YOU'D LIKE TO DISCUSS
YES I WILL INDEED TRY TO BE
BRIEF I'M SHE LOVE OXLEY THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE CHILD
ABUSE PREVENTION CENTER WHICH IS
A STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION.
AND I AM GRATEFUL THAT WE HAVE
BEEN USING AMERICORPS AS A KEY
STRATEGY FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS
IN THIS DAY AND TO LET YOU KNOW
WHAT THAT MEANS IS ALMOST FOUR
HUNDRED AND INDIVIDUALS TODAY
OUR AMERICORPS MEMBERS. FOR
HELPING TO PREVENT CHILD ABUSE
AND NEGLECT.
THEY ARE SUCCESSFUL WITH 97% OF
THE FAMILIES THAT THEY WORK WITH
AND WE CAN PROVIDE THAT SERVICE
THROUGH AMERICORPS HOME
VISITATION THE FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTER SERVICES FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS A FAMILY A YEAR.
AND THE COST FOR A CHILD WHO
GOES INTO CHILD WELFARE IS TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND SO THERE'S QUITE A
RETURN ON INVESTMENT.
AND THERE'S BEEN A RECENT --
VERY RECENT REPORT THAT'S COME
OUT AND SAID THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
TO SPEND ABOUT NINETEEN TWO
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR ON THE
IMPACTS OF CHILD ABUSE NEGLECT.
SO WE THINK THIS IS IS A
SERIOUSLY VALID A RETURN ON
INVESTMENT AND A REALLY GREAT
STEP FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND ONE OTHER QUICK THING WE'RE
ABLE TO RECRUIT PEOPLE TO BE
AMERICORPS MEMBERS FROM WITH IN
COMMUNITIES.
SO THEY REFLECT THE COMMUNITIES
THEY'RE SERVING AS AN EXAMPLE
ONE FAMILY RESOURCE CENTER HERE
IN SACRAMENTO PROVIDE SERVICES
IN FOURTEEN DIFFERENT LANGUAGES
SO WE'RE ON THE GROUND WE'RE
GIVING PEOPLE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THEIR OWN FUTURE.
AS WELL AS FOR THOSE THAT THEY
SERVE.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND FOR YOUR COMMENTS --
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
LA OR FINANCE NO PROTEST ANY
PUBLIC COMMENTS.
GOOD WE'RE STREAMING ALONG THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU THIS
ITEM WILL BE HELD OPEN
[inaudible]
ANYONE ECONOMIST [inaudible]
YEAH.
SO LET'S GO BACK.
TO THE FIRST ITEM OF FOR ITEMS
TO BE HEARD.
ISSUE NUMBER ONE STATEWIDE
FINANCE INSURANCE POOL.
MISTER DALE FOUNTAIN WITH ENACT
UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE FOR
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
WELCOME.
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES
TO MAKE A PRESENTATION
[inaudible]
YES.
LEGISLATORS GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM ON DALE FOUNTAIN
CHAIRPERSON AND CEO OF AN ACT
UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE FOR
CALIFORNIA.
I REPRESENT THE LARGEST SINGLE
PAYER ORGANIZATION IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH OVER A HUNDRED EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND SUPPORTERS WHO ACTUALLY
LIVE IN CALIFORNIA.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHY I'M HERE
TODAY.
IT'S NOT THROUGH CALLING OR
LETTERS OR BEING POLITE.
THAT GOT ME THIS PRESENTATION.
NO IT WAS BY TELLING FILL TANG
THAT HE WON'T BE REELECTED NEXT
YEAR.
NOW I WAS PROMISED.
I WAS PROMISED HELP WITH
ACTUARIES AND I WAS PROMISED A
FULL FIFTEEN TO THIRTY MINUTE
PRESENTATION BY TING STAFFER.
CHRISTIAN GRIFFITH.
BUT I WAS LIED TO BECAUSE THIS
CAN ONLY BE A FIVE MINUTE SPEECH
NOT RECEIVE NOTHING.
BUT A GOOGLE SEARCH WOULDN'T
HAVE TOLD ME.
OBVIOUSLY I CAN'T GIVE A FULL
PRESENTATION WITH ONLY FIVE
MINUTES SO I PARED IT DOWN
CONSIDERABLY AS YOU'LL HEAR IN A
MOMENT.
LET'S GET TO THE HISTORY OF
SINGLE PAYER LEGISLATION IN THE
LEGISLATURE'S RESPONSE.
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS.
IN MARCH OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN SB
FIVE SIXTY TWO WAS INTRODUCED.
PASSED THE SENATE.
AND STOPPED BY THE ASSEMBLY.
OKAY.
WE AT LEAST MY AWARD.
UNDERSTOOD THAT THE STATE
CONSTITUTION NEEDED TO BE
AMENDED TO EXEMPT HEALTH CARE
FUNDING FROM ARTICLE THIRTEEN
BEAT THE STATE SPENDING CAP.
AND ARTICLE SIXTEEN A. K. A.
PROP.
NINETY EIGHT WELL DESPITE SO
MANY LEGISLATORS CLAIMING TO
SUPPORT SINGLE PAYER.
NO ONE SUPPORTED THE NECESSARY
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THE ASSEMBLY HELD HEARINGS ONE
OF WHICH I WAS A PANELIST ON AND
ONE OF THE BILLS THAT CAME OUT
WAS THE COUNCIL ON HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS WHICH WAS
TASKED TO RESEARCH AND RECOMMEND
A SINGLE PAYER SYSTEM.
IT PASSED THE ASSEMBLY AND THEN
WAS INSERTED INTO THE BUDGET BY
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN HIMSELF AND
ENACTED INTO LAW.
IN THE INTERIM ASH KALRA
INTRODUCED A PRICE CONTROL BILL
IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN IT PASSED THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE.
AND THEN HE QUIETLY WITHDREW IT
WITH NO EXPLANATION GIVEN.
PRICE CONTROLS ARE ESSENTIAL TO
ALL UNIVERSAL HEALTHCARE
INFORMATIONS.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE DIDN'T WANT
TO TACKLE THAT EITHER.
IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN ELECTIONS
MOST OF YOU CAMPAIGNED ON SINGLE
PAYER.
OR AT LEAST SIGNIFICANTLY
REFORMING OR TAKEN SUBSTANTIAL
STEPS TO MAKE HEALTHCARE MORE
AFFORDABLE.
PRESENT DAY.
GAVIN NEWSOM STILL HASN'T MADE
HIS THREE REQUIRED APPOINTMENTS
TO THE COUNCIL ON HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS.
AND THE COUNCIL HAS ALREADY
MISSED ITS FIRST MEETING.
ACCORDING TO THE INFORMATION I
GOT FROM TONI ATKINS AND ANTHONY
RENDON OFFICES.
THEY SOMEHOW HAVE APPOINTED THE
SAME PERSON.
AND DESPITE YOUR CAMPAIGN
PROMISES NONE OF YOU HAVE TAKEN
ANY ACTION BEFORE THE FEBRUARY
TWENTY SECOND DEADLINE FOR NEW
BILLS.
SO MUCH FOR SINGLE PAYER.
OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS WE DID
SOME POLLING. 61% OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT INCREASED
TAXES FOR SINGLE PAYER. 51% OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT ELIMINATING
PRIVATE INSURANCE FOR SINGLE
PAYER.
AND 67% OF CALIFORNIANS OPPOSE
PENALTIES FOR THOSE WHO CAN'T
AFFORD HEALTH INSURANCE.
ALL OF THESE POLLS ARE AVAILABLE
ON OUR WEBSITE FOR YOU TO
ANALYZE.
SO LET'S GET TO THE STATE WIDE
HEALTH INSURANCE POOL.
AS I'VE SAID ON PERRANCE DOWN
SOMETHING EXTREMELY SIMPLE.
HERE IT IS SKIFF OR STATE FUND.
WILL BE OPEN TO THE PUBLIC FOR
REGULAR HEALTH INSURANCE AS A
PUBLIC OPTION.
STATE FUND ALREADY HAS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE ACTUARIES AND THE PROVIDERS.
AND IT IS NOT SUBJECT TO THE CAN
LIMIT.
PROP NINETY EIGHT WAIVERS ARE
LIMITED BY ERISA.
AND IT COST THE STATE ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING TO DO THIS.
NOW WE'RE NOT TAKING NO FOR AN
ANSWER.
THIS IS YOUR LAST CHANCE WE'VE
TRIED EVERYTHING ELSE.
THIS NEW MANDATE FOR STATE FIND
NEEDS TO SHOW UP IN THE MAY
BUDGET GET PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR.
ARE NONE OF YOU ARE COMING BACK
AFTER THE TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION.
IF YOU SURVIVE YOU PRIMARIES.
MY WORK SUPPORTERS GOT YOU
ELECTED IN MY ORG SUPPORTERS
COLLECT SOMEONE ELSE.
SEE THAT WAS SIMPLE NOW DO YOUR
JOB HAVE A GREAT DAY.
THANK YOU LIKEWISE [inaudible]
OKAY.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ON THAT.
MOVING ON TO ISSUE ITEM NUMBER.
TEN TAXPAYER OUTRAGE AND
PREPARATION ASSISTANCE
.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHRIS STILL
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- YOU
HAVE BEFORE YOU TODAY A PROPOSAL
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET -- TO
PROVIDE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH TO CONDUCT
OUTREACH RELATED TO THE EARNED
INCOME TAX PROGRAM IN THE
EXPANSION PROPOSED THEREFORE.
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET -- I
JUST KNOW THAT OUT REACHES
CURRENTLY PERFORMED FOR EITC BY
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD PURSUANT
TO A INTERAGENCY AGREEMENT WITH
THE DEPARTMENT COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT.
AND THAT -- WE THINK FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD DONE A VERY GOOD JOB
WITH THIS AND WE SALUTE THEM FOR
THEIR EFFORTS IN THIS PROPOSALS
INTO A REFLECTION UPON THEM.
THIS IS JUST A GOOD IDEA TO GO
AHEAD AND BUILD UP THE SUCCESS
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD HAS --
ACHIEVED AND PROVIDE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO OPR TO GO AHEAD
AND I WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT AND JUST COULD SHE
BE MORE SUCCESS IN TERMS ABOUT
RICH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE GENERAL
PUBLIC COMMENTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
NOW YOU LEASE ON THE ONE WITH
THE UNITED WAYS A CALIFORNIA --
AND THE THE IDC COALITION
REPRESENTING OVER TWENTY
ORGANIZATIONS WHO WORK -- TO
INCREASED UPTAKE OF THE CREDIT
AND STRENGTHEN THE CREDIT --
UNITED WAY SO STRONG SUPPORTER
OF THE E. I. T. C. IN GENERAL
AND WE'RE ALSO DEEPLY INVOLVED
IN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF FREE
TAX PREP AND AS WELL AND OF THE
I. T. C. OUT REACH -- WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE ASSEMBLY
ENSURING THAT -- OUT REACHING
FOR TAX PURPOSES A CONTINUED A
PRIORITY AND INVESTMENT -- AND
WHILE THE PROPOSAL OF A FIVE
FIVE MILLION IS A GOOD START YOU
KNOW -- WE WANT TO URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER INCREASING --
THE INVESTMENT TO TWENTY MILLION
A YEAR FOR CONTINUOUS FUNDING --
FOR MINIMUM OF THREE YEARS SO WE
KNOW THAT OUR REACH MATTERS --
AND NOT REACH MATTERS ALSO WHEN
IT'S DONE BY A TRUSTED
MESSENGERS -- US WHILE WE'RE
ABLE TO MOST -- A DEADLY REACH
THE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE --
FOR FOR THE CREDIT -- WE ALSO
KNOW THAT AS THE POPULATION OF
THOSE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR EITC
IS INCREASE SCENE BUT IT'S ALSO
GOING TO BE.
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE
TO RAMP UP THE FUNDING AND THE
INVESTMENT AROUND FREE TAX PREP
AN HOUR EACH.
THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS CUT A MUST FOR THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER WE WE JUST ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
THE UNITED WAY THIS IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT -- TO
DOLLARS THAT THEY'RE IN THE
BUDGET WE ARE -- HAPPY FOR THE
FIVE MILLION BUT OUR OUR HOPE IS
TO ULTIMATELY GET TWENTY MILLION
THIS -- IS MUCH NEEDED MONEY THE
POPULATION HERE AS WAS STATED BY
THE ARC MY COLLEAGUE FROM UNITED
WAY SHIFTS AND CHANGES SO YOU DO
NEED ONE VALUED AND TRUSTED
MEMBERS IN THE COMMUNITY TO HELP
FOLKS WITH THIS.
BUT ALSO ON TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE CONSISTENTLY AVAILABLE
SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
BY TREVOR ROGERS WITH THE EAGLES
STATE OPPORTUNITY FOUNDATION --
WANT TO ECHO -- OUR COLLEAGUES --
PREVIOUS COMMENTS -- THIS
FUNDING HAS.
ENABLED -- ORGANIZATION SUCH AS
OURS -- TO REACH A MILLIONS OF
POTENTIAL TAX FILERS AND BRING
BACK BILLIONS IN STATE AND
FEDERAL EITC DOLLARS -- WE ALSO
ECHO -- THE PREVIOUS COMMENTS --
AND APPLAUD -- THE ASSEMBLIES --
PRIOR FUNDING OF THIS -- OUR
REACH -- AND HOPE TO REVISIT --
LATER IN THE BUDGET PROCESS FOR
POTENTIALLY MORE FUNDING THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MAX MORE
BARGAIN WITH UNITED WAYS OF
CALIFORNIA AND I ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO AGREE WITH THE PRIOR.
COMMENTS AND SHARE A QUICK STORY
OF A CALLIE IDC RECIPIENT.
LAURIE I'M SORRY VERY BRIEF
STORY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
IN A MCKINNEY RESIDENT LOW ABOUT
THIS THIRTY YEAR OLD SINGLE
MOTHER OF FOUR CHILDREN -- SHE
HAD AN INCOME OF ONLY THREE
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE DOLLARS AND HER TOTAL TAX
REFUND WAS THREE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN DOLLARS.
FIFTEEN HUNDRED AND TWO DOLLARS
OF WHICH CAME FROM THAT CALLIE
ITC SO YOU CAN SEE THIS REALLY
MAKES A BIG IMPACT IN THE LIVES
OF THAT COMMUNITY THAT WE SERVE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SONOMA GASKINS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE IN CALIFORNIA
I'D LIKE TO LIE MY COMMENTS WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES UNITED WAYS IN
OTHERS AND JUST REALLY -- URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO CONTINUE THINK
ABOUT OUT OF REACH AYE AYE PLOT
THAT WE ARE HERE TODAY TO TALK
ABOUT THE CURRENT INVESTMENT BUT
REALLY TO EXPAND THAT FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE MOST
VULNERABLE PARTICULARLY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
AND HOW AND CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
ASSIST TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
GET THE INCOME SUPPORT THAT THEY
NEED THAT THEY'VE WORKED HARD
FOR THANK YOU THANK YOU -- STAFF
IS RECOMMENDED APPROVING. FIVE
MILLION AT THE FTV FOR TAXPAYER
OUT REACH IN LIEU OF FUNDING AT
OPR SIR MOTION FOR THAT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
Q. [inaudible]
NAZARIAN AYE. TO LACKEY
[inaudible]
LAKE SENTINEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT ITEM ISSUE NUMBER.
ELEVEN THIS IS THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE.
UPDATE ON FISCAL PROJECT
IMPLEMENTATION AND PROP PAYMENT
TRAILER BILL
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON
SORRY.
I FEEL LIKE IT'S MORNING AS WELL.
MY NAME IS MERRIAM BARCELONA
ENGINEER -- AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF THE FINANCIAL INFORMATION
SYSTEM FOR CALIFORNIA OUR
DISCOUNT.
AND I THOUGHT I WOULD START WITH
JUST A VERY HIGH LEVEL.
OVERVIEW -- AGAIN JUST JUST TO
TO REFRESH THE COMMITTEES --
MEMORY HERE.
THIS GIRL IS ONE OF THE LARGEST
MOST DYNAMIC I. T. UNDERTAKINGS
THAT THE STATE HAS -- DEPLOYED.
THAT IT IS NOT ONLY AN I. T.
PROJECT BUT ALSO A BUSINESS
TRANSFORMATION EFFORT.
WE ARE -- DEPLOYED IN A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY TWO DEPARTMENT SO A
100% OF THOSE DEPARTMENTS WE HAD
SET OUT -- TO IMPLEMENT AND AS
THE SCOPE HAS BEEN -- THEY ARE
IMPLEMENTED THERE UTILIZING THE
SYSTEM.
WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT SOME OF
THEM ARE HAVING PIECES OF THEIR
LEGACY SYSTEM STILL IN USE UNTIL
WE FINISH -- THE FUNCTIONALITY
THAT WE ARE DEPLOYING.
WHERE 98% OF THE FUNCTIONALITY
THAT WE SET OUT TO DEPLOY IS IN
PRODUCTION?
THAT INCLUDES THE BUDGET SO WE
HAVE ESTIMATED TWO HUNDRED
NINETY THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
BUDGETARY EXPENDITURES.
ARE THREE OUR SYSTEM AS OF YOU
KNOW WITH INCLUDING THIS CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR.
ADD TO THAT REPRESENT 65% OF
TOTAL BUDGETARY EXPENDITURES.
IN OCTOBER WE BROUGHT ON THE
TREASURY FUNCTIONS WHICH IS TWO
TRILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
BANKING TRANSACTIONS THAT THE
CONTRACT THAT THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE -- PERFORMS
NOW UTILIZING OUR SYSTEM.
WE HAVE -- NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND
PROCUREMENT OUR BIDDERS AND
SUPPLIERS THAT ARE UTILIZING OUR
SYSTEM AS WELL TO DO BUSINESS
OUT OF SELLING GOODS AND
SERVICES TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE CURRENTLY OVER EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND END USERS THOSE ARE
STATE EMPLOYEES UTILIZING OUR
SYSTEM TO DO THEIR DAY TO DAY
JOBS -- I JUST WANT TO BRING
YOUR ATTENTION TO BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT THE QUESTION THAT WAS ASKED
SPECIFICALLY OF US WAS FOR THE
UPDATE ON THE SCO COMPONENTS AND
WHERE WE ARE ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT FINAL
FUNCTIONALITY.
WE IN S. P. R..
SEVEN WE BROKE OUT THE
DEPLOYMENT METHODOLOGY FROM A
WATERFALL RIPOFF THE BANDAID
DOING IT ALL AT ONCE TO TAKING
THAT FUNCTIONALITY BREAKING IT
INTO BUSINESS PROCESSES AND WE
RELEASED THAT.
WHEN WHAT WE WERE CALLING
MILESTONES MILESTONES ONE TWO
AND HALF OF THREE ARE FULLY
DEPLOYED?
AND MILESTONE THREE BE -- FOR
AND MILESTONE FIVE WE ARE
LOOKING.
TO BE DELAYED.
AND TO INSURE THAT WE HAVE ALL
OF THE PROPER TESTING IN PLACE
BUT WE DEPLOY.
SO THAT IS -- AN ITEM THAT IS
BEFORE MY STEERING KID COMMITTEE
TOMORROW AND WE'LL BE BACK TO
LEGISLATURE WHEN WE HAVE.
A DEFINITIVE ON WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT [inaudible]
CONTROLLERS OFFICE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS GEORGE
LOW LISTEN I'M THE CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER AT THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE -- WE ARE
IN THE MIDDLE OF IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE CONTROL FUNCTIONS WITHIN
THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE SAYS --
THE DIRECTOR MENTIONED -- AS
SOME OF THE DEPARTMENTS HAVE
BEEN STRUGGLING WITH FINALIZING
SOME OF THEIR WORK ISSUES WITH
THE SYSTEM WE HAVE AS WELL.
AND WE ARE WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE DISCOUNT DEPARTMENT AND
OUR PARTNERS TO MAKE SURE THAT --
THE FUNCTIONALITY IS WORKING
PROPERLY THAT ENHANCEMENTS THAT
MAY NEED TO BE MADE ARE
IMPLEMENTED SO THAT THE WORKLOAD
ISSUES BOTH OF THE DEPARTMENTS
AND ALSO MY OFFICE -- CAN BE
RESOLVED.
AND WE ARE WORKING DILIGENTLY TO
MAKE SURE THAT HAPPENS HENCE THE
POSSIBLE DELAY THAT ARE THE
DIRECTOR MENTIONED OF THE
MILESTONE THREE B. AND MILESTONE
FOUR AND FIVE FUNCTIONALITY.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYTHING THAT HAS BEEN
IMPLEMENTED IS WORKING THE WAY
IT NEEDS TO BE WORKING AND THAT
THE WORKLOAD -- IS IT IS AT A
LEVEL THAT THE STAFF CAN KEEP UP
WITH IT.
AND DO OF RICHARD GILL AND
RIDICULOUS AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
AND THE DEPARTMENT CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER BUT ALSO MY
DAY JOB ON THE FISCAL PROJECT
SPONSOR.
TAKEN ON THAT ROLE ABOUT SIX
MONTHS AGO -- SO SINCE I RETURN
TO FINANCE AND AND STEPPED INTO
THE ROLE PROJECT SPONSOR --
WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY HARD AS
A STEERING COMMITTEE AND AS A
PROJECT IN AS AS AS THE
GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE BRING THE FINAL
STAGES THIS PROJECT ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE.
AND DO THAT SUCCESSFULLY -- IT'S
NO SECRET SOMEWHERE DEPARTMENTS
ARE STRUGGLING WITH THINGS LIKE
MONTH IN CLOSE YEAR AND CLOSE --
SOME OF THOSE ARE AS AS RESULT
OF DESIGN DECISIONS THAT WERE.
TO THE VERGE OF MOVING PASS BUT
WE WE HAVE THIS LAST HURDLE
BEFORE SO AS MISTER ENGINEER
SAID THERE'S A STEERING
COMMITTEE MEETING TOMORROW OR
THE PARTNERS WILL DISCUSS --
PERHAPS A CHANGE IN STRATEGY ON
THE FINAL ROLL OUT OF THE
CONTROLLERS FUNCTIONALITY -- AND
ASSUMING THAT HAPPENS -- IT'S
LIKELY THE ADMINISTRATION WILL
BE BACK WITH THE PROPOSAL
BETWEEN NOW IN AMERICA'S AND THE
LAYOUT.
UP BRIAN METZGER LA -- FIRST WE
HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE --
BUT WE DO CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONCERNS -- WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROJECT --
SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS INCLUDE
THE CONTINUED ON BOARDING OF
DEPARTMENTS THAT WERE PART OF
THE JULY TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
RELEASE.
AND THEIR CONTINUED USE OF
LEGACY SYSTEMS AND THE POTENTIAL
DELAYS -- IN COMPLETING THEIR
YEAR END FINANCIAL STATEMENTS
LIKE A COMPANY THAT -- WE REMAIN
CONCERNED THAT THERE ARE NUMBER
DEPARTMENTS IF IT HAVE BEEN
DEFERRED OUTSIDE OF THE PROJECT
SCOPE -- AND THAT THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH BRINGING THOSE
DEPARTMENTS ONLINE -- WILL NOT
BE CAPTURED IN THE TOTAL PROJECT
COST CURRENTLY.
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
ADDITIONAL COSTS FOR DEPARTMENTS
THAT ARE ALREADY TRANSACTING
FISCALE -- RELATED TO ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES ARE FUNDING THAT ARE
BEING REQUESTED THROUGH THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET --
WERE AWARE OF SIX BCP'S WHERE
THAT IS OCCURRING.
AND WE REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT
DEPARTMENTS FACING CHALLENGES
CLOSING THEIR MONTH END AND YEAR
END FINANCIAL STATEMENTS --
LOOKING IN NUMBERS YEAR OVER
YEAR -- THERE ARE CONCERNS
AROUND YOU KNOW THE THE THE
PERCENTAGE THAT ARE ABLE TO
CLOSE AT LEAST THE FIRST MONTH --
OF THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FISCAL YEAR.
AND SO TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE
ARE CONTINUE DELAYS AND AND
AGAIN THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE QUITE A BIT
LARGER IN THIS LATEST RELEASE --
THAT COULD AFFECT THE TIMELINESS
OR QUALITY OF THE STATE'S ANNUAL
FINANCIAL REPORT -- WE ARE AWARE
THAT THERE ARE CHANGES FOURTH
COMING IN THE PROJECT BASS LINE
AND WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR
THAT PROCESS GOING FORWARD.
SO I'VE BEEN PRETTY QUIET IN
THIS COMMITTEE MEETING BUT I AM
GONNA PIPE UP AT THIS POINT --
AND I KNOW I CAN TELL FROM THE
PANEL THAT -- IS NOT OF YOUR
PARTICULAR EXCITED TO BE HERE ON
THIS TOPIC. FOR MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC IF I CAN I THINK THIS
PROJECT WAS DESCRIBED JUST A FEW
MINUTES GOES A DYNAMIC PRODUCT.
PROJECT AND I THINK IT
REPRESENTS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
FAILURES.
IN STATE GOVERNMENT IT'S AN
EMBARRASSMENT TO STATE
GOVERNMENT IT'S BEEN A DISASTER.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A PROJECT
THAT STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND
FIVE IT IS NOW.
200-014- A PROJECT THAT HAS HAD
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF OVER ON LATEST TAB IS NINE
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS.
AND NOW WHAT WE'RE HEARING THIS
AT THEIR CONTINUED DELAYS -- I'D
LIKE TO SECTION THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE IF YOU
COULD ARTICULATE.
I'VE UNDERSTAND THERE'S A LETTER
SENT THE LEGISLATURE I DON'T
HAVE IN FRONT OF ME THAT.
HAS ADDITIONAL CONCERNS THAT
THIS SYSTEM COULD CAUSE DELAYS
IN THE REPORTING OF ACTOR FISCAL
STATEMENTS FOR THE STATE'S
KAFFIR.
WHICH COULD I UNDERSTAND
POTENTIALLY IMPACT OUR STATE'S
CREDIT RATING.
COULD YOU ELABORATE ON THAT AND
I'D LIKE TO HEAR A RESPONSE FROM
THE PROJECT.
THERE COULD BE A VARIETY OF
REASONS WHY THE STATE'S KAFFIR
COULD BE DELAYED -- THEY COULD
BE SYSTEM ISSUES THE COULD BE
WORKLOAD ISSUES WHEN YOU SAY
COULD BE SIR I'M SORRY WHAT
WHAT'S THE ANSWER.
YOU JUST DON'T ACTUALLY EVEN
KNOW WHAT THE ANSWER IS.
WHAT I'M TRYING TO SAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IS THAT THE KAFIR CAN BE
DELAYED AND OR HAVE ISSUES FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS?
OUR AND STATE AUDITOR CAN
PROBABLY EXPLAIN WHAT THOSE
REASONS ARE.
THE THE CAPPER WHICH IS THE
STATE'S AUDITED FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS CAN BE DELAYED
BECAUSE OF COMPLEXITY IS HAVING
TO WHAT WHAT WHAT WE HAVE TO DO
THAT PARTICULAR HERE.
IT COULD BE DELAYED BECAUSE OF
THE WORKLOAD ISSUES WHETHER IT'S
FISCALE -- WORKLOAD ISSUES.
OR OTHER ISSUES WITH IN OTHER
SYSTEM SO THERE'S A THE CARD THE
CAPPER IS A COMPLEX ANIMAL THE
KAFFIR PROJECT PLAN EVERY YEAR
HAS OVER NINE HUNDRED
DELIVERABLES. FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO COMPLETE IT.
AND HAVE THE STATE AUDITOR ISSUE
AN OPINION.
SO THERE ARE A VARIETY OF ISSUES
AND EVERY YEAR IT'S SOMETHING
DIFFERENT IT'S NEVER THE SAME
THING TWICE THE CONTROLLERS
CONCERN THIS YEAR WAS SOME OF
THE ISSUES WE WERE HAVING WITH
THIS GAL.
AND NOT NECESSARILY -- TECHNICAL
ISSUES BUT WORKLOAD ISSUES THAT
WE WERE HAVING WITH THIS GAL MAY
CAUSE A DELAY IN THIS YEAR'S AND
OR NEXT YEAR'S KAFFIR.
AND ALSO AS THE LA -- MENTION
BECAUSE SOME OF THE DEPARTMENTS
ARE HAVING TROUBLE CLOSING THEIR
BOOKS AND PROVIDING THE
FINANCIAL INFORMATION THAT IS
WHAT THE CONTROLLERS CONCERNED
ABOUT AND HER LETTER WAS.
PRIMARILY DESIGNED OR INTENDED
TO JUST GET THAT WORD OUT THERE
THAT SHE HAS THAT CONCERN THAT
WE FOCUS ON THE ENHANCEMENTS TO
THE SYSTEM THAT WILL HELP
WORKLOAD ISSUES.
BOTH AT THE DEPARTMENT LEVEL AND
SCO LEVEL IN ORDER TO GET THINGS
RESOLVED AND GET THE KAFFIR AND
OF THE OTHER FINANCIAL --
PRODUCTS THAT WE NEED TO PUT OUT.
ON TIME THAT'S WHAT THE LETTER
WAS INTENDED TO DO THE
CONTROLLER HAS FULL SUPPORT IS
FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE PROJECT
HAS FULL CONFIDENCE IN THE
PROJECT WILL SUCCEED -- THE
PROJECT WILL PROVIDE
EFFICIENCIES BUT IT'S A BELL
SHAPED CURVE RIGHT IT'S GOES UP
IT UP HERE FOR AWHILE THEN IT
WILL EVENTUALLY WILL GO BACK
DOWN.
BUT IT HAS TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THE TOOLS THAT WE NEED NOT ONLY
FOR THE DEPARTMENTS BUT ALSO FOR
THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE --
CONTROL FUNCTIONALITY TO WORK.
IF I COULD ASK FOR RESPONSE FROM
THE PROJECT LET ME SAY I I A I
HAVE A LOT OF FAITH IN OUR
CONTROL -- AND I A BELIEVER
ASSESSMENT THAT -- THERE ARE
CONTINUE NEEDS. FOR NEEDS FOR
DELAY BUT GIVEN THE HISTORY OF
THIS PROJECT GIVEN THE FACT THAT
SOMEONE BORN IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WHO'S NOW
IN HIGH SCHOOL WOULD EXPERIENCE
AN AWFUL LOT OF DIFFERENT TYPES
OF TECHNOLOGIES OVER THE PAST
FOURTEEN YEARS.
MANY OF US HAVE JUST NO FAITH
THAT THIS PROGRAM IS EVER GOING
TO COME TO COMPLETION SO -- TELL
US WHY WE SHOULD HAVE SOME FAITH.
SO THE PROJECT STARTED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE AS JUST THE
BUDGETARY REPLACEMENT SYSTEMS
THAT WAS OUR FIRST INTRODUCTION
TO THIS PROJECT.
AND THAT COST ESTIMATE WAS AT A
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS JUST TO REPLACE THE FOUR
MAIN FRAMES.
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
BY TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN IT WAS
EVIDENT THAT THERE WERE A NUMBER
OF OTHER SYSTEMS STATEWIDE THAT
NEEDED TO BE REPLACED.
SO IN TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN THE
STATE COMPTROLLER THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
PROCUREMENT DIVISION.
AS WELL AS THE GOVERNOR'S -- THE
ORIGINAL SCOPE OF THE BUDGET
BEING SYSTEM REPLACEMENT WERE
COMBINED INTO WHAT IS THE
FINANCIAL INFORMATION SYSTEM FOR
CALIFORNIA FISCAL.
THAT ESTIMATED THAT TIMES OF THE
SCOPE SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGED AND
THAT INITIAL -- ESTIMATE WAS AT
ONE POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE NEXT FEW
YEARS AS WE HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTING THIS PROJECT BOTH
THE SCOPE AS WELL AS THE
SCHEDULE HAS SHIFTED.
BASED ON THE NEEDS ARE THE
CURRENT NEEDS OF THE DEPARTMENTS
AND WHERE THE CONTROL AGENCIES
AS WELL AS IN ONE CASE WE
CHANGED SIGNIFICANTLY.
THE WAY WE ON BOARD DEPARTMENTS
WE WENT FROM THE IDEA IT WHEN WE
WERE ONE POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS TO HAVE.
PEOPLE IN EVERY SINGLE
DEPARTMENTS TO HELP WITH THIS
TRANSITION TO A TRAIN THE
TRAINER MODEL WHICH IS WHAT WE
ULTIMATELY IMPLEMENTED.
THAT IN SOME PART WAS DUE TO THE
FINANCIAL CONDITION OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AT THAT TIME.
SO.
THAT IS THE HISTORY OF OF THE
DOLLARS AND THE SCOPE HAS
CHANGED HAS BEEN ADDED
SUBTRACTED WE'VE ADDED
REPLACEMENT FUNCTIONALITY -- FOR
THE BACK OFFICE AT THE
DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES
WHICH WAS OUT OF SCOPE AND IS
NOW IN SCOPE AND WE DEPLOYED
THAT SO THERE'S A NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT.
HAVE BEEN DONE THE PROJECT IS
TREMENDOUSLY SUCCESSFUL.
IN THAT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
DEPARTMENTS ARE UTILIZING IT --
FOR THEIR ACCOUNTING ALL STATE
DEPARTMENTS ARE UTILIZING FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT AND DEPLOYMENT
OF TE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THE LAST THREE YEARS WE HAVE --
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAS BEEN
INTRODUCED UTILIZING THE FISCAL
SYSTEM.
AND THE MAN SINCE TWENTY SIXTEEN
WE HAVE PRETTY EIGHT BEEN ABLE
TO PRODUCE A WEEK THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE HAS BEEN ABLE TO
PRODUCE.
THE ENACTED BUDGET WITH THE SAME
LEVEL OF DETAIL THAT THE
INTRODUCED BUDGET IS WHICH IS
MUCH MORE BENEFICIAL TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO THE PUBLIC AS A
MINISTRY.
IF I MAY COULD YOU JUST RESPOND
TO THE ISSUES OF RACE IN THE
CONTROLLERS LETTER BECAUSE AGAIN
I THINK.
WHAT I THOUGHT I WAS RESPONDING
TO THE WHOLE FAILURE PIECE TO
START THAT'S HELPFUL I I THINK
WHAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HEAR?
MORE DELAYS MORE BUREAUCRACIES.
WHEN IT COMES TO WHY THIS IS THE
CASE?
I HAVE BEEN ON THIS COMMITTEE IN
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE NOW THIS IS
MY MY FIFTH YEAR AND EVERY YEAR
I SAY I THINK YOU KNOW I KEEP
ASKING THESE QUESTIONS AND I AM
TEMPTED NOT TO VOTE.
FOR ANYTHING ELSE TO CONTINUE
THIS PROGRAM BUT I KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS AND WE'RE SURE
EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
THAT THINGS ARE ON TRACK AND
THEN WE GET YET ANOTHER LETTER
SAYING.
THAT A KEY PARTNER IN THE
FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT OF OUR
STATE.
DOES NOT HAVE FULL FAITH AND
CONFIDENCE YET THAT THE SYSTEM
IS READY TO GO.
SO AGAIN AS SAID THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE DID STATE.
THAT WE ARE WORKING WITH THEM TO
PRIORITIZE WHATEVER ENHANCEMENTS
WILL HELP ASSIST THE DEPARTMENTS.
WE ARE WRECKED WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THE DEPARTMENTS DO CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE.
AND WE ARE RE PRIORITIZING AND
REDIRECTING SOME OF THE EXISTING
CONTRACT DOLLARS FROM.
WORKING ON SOME OF THE FUTURE
FUNCTIONALITY THAT THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT WHICH WE ARE
DELAYING TO ASSIST THE
DEPARTMENTS -- WITH THEIR MONTH
ENDING YEAR AND CLOSE THERE IS
KEY ENHANCEMENTS THAT WILL BE
DEPLOYED IN HAVE BEEN DEPLOYED
IN THE RECENT WEEKS.
WE CONTINUE TO WE'VE IMPLEMENTED
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
ENHANCEMENTS SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF THIS YEAR. TO THE SYSTEM SO
IT IS A CONSTANT DYNAMICALLY
CHANGING SYSTEM TO MEET THE
NEEDS AT ANY GIVEN TIME.
OF A HUNDRED FIFTY TWO
DEPARTMENTS EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
AND USERS AND FOR CONTROL
AGENCIES THAT ARE BOTH
CONSTITUTIONAL AND STATUTORY
RESPONSIBILITIES.
SO THE COMPLEXITY OF THIS
PROJECT CANNOT BE OVERSTATED AND
I BELIEVE THAT WE ARE ON A PATH.
TO GET THIS VERY I MEAN THAT WE
ARE LESS THAN TWO HUNDRED
REQUIREMENTS AT A FORTY FIVE
HUNDRED OR FORTY TWO HUNDRED
PLUS.
REQUIREMENTS IN THE SYSTEM WHEN
WE SET OUT THEY'VE BEEN DEPLOYED.
AS WELL AS THE ENHANCEMENTS TO
THE SYSTEM WE WILL CONTINUE TO
PARTNER WITH THE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE OF MY OTHER PARTNERS TO
MAKE SURE THAT A QUALITY PRODUCT
IS PUT OUT ON THE STREET AND
THAT.
WE DO NOT HAVE -- ISSUES WITH
INTEGRITY OR QUALITY OF THAT YOU
KNOW COULD HAPPEN IF WE RUSHED
TO DEPLOYMENT BEFORE THE THE
SYSTEM IS FULLY TESTED AND THIS
DISTORTS REMAINING FUNCTIONALITY.
IS ACCEPTED BY THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE SO THE
COMMITTEE REPORT SAYS THE
CONTROLS FUNCTIONALITY WAS
DELAYED REPEATEDLY AND IS STILL
YEARS AWAY FROM BEING REALIZED.
IT'S HARD TO BE SYMPATHETIC TO
THE CALLS FOR YET ANOTHER DELAY
USING THE SAME ARGUMENTS OF
IMPENDING DOOM THAT BEEN USEFUL
LAST FIVE YEARS WHAT'S THE
WHAT'S THE DATE THAT WE WOULD
EXPECT THAT THIS PROJECT WOULD
BE FINALIZED.
IF I GET ASKED TO THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE.
GIVE ANY SENSE.
AS FAR AS THE SCHEDULE GOES NOW
WE'RE LOOKING AT JULY OF TWENTY
TWENTY FOR THE FINAL TWO
MILESTONES TO BE RELEASED.
WHICH ARE MILESTONE FOREIGN
MILESTONE FIVE I BELIEVE -- AND
THAT WOULD BE THE LAST TWO
PIECES OF FUNCTIONALITY THAT
WOULD GO LIVE AT THAT POINT.
OUR OUR OFFICE WOULD NEED TO
PRODUCE A KAFFIR.
ARTIFICE GAL.
THE FOR THE FOR THAT FISCAL YEAR --
SO IT TO TO BE ABLE TO SEE IF
THE WORK PROPERLY TO PRODUCE THE
KAFFIR WOULD TAKE ANOTHER
ANOTHER YEARRIGHT IT WOULD BE.
THE FOLLOWING FISCAL YEAR BUT
THE FUNCTIONALITY WILL ALL BE IN
PLACE BY JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY
HAS THIS BEEN BROUGHT TO THE
ATTENTION OF THE NEW GOVERNOR.
A FEW DISCUSSES WITH HIS TEAM.
WE HAVE BRIEFED ADMINISTRATION
ON THE STATUS OF THE PROJECT YES
AND ARE THEY WHAT WHAT IS THEIR
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS -- AS I SAID
IN MY EARLIER COMMENTS -- SO
MINISTER COMMITTEE TAKES AN
ACTION THAT WE EXPECT TO TAKE --
TOMORROW -- YOU SHOULD EXPECTED
MINISTRATION WILL SUBMIT A
REVISED PROPOSAL BETWEEN NOW AND
THE MAY REVISION FOR ADDITIONAL
BUDGET EXPENDITURES TO PUSH THIS
PROJECT ACROSS THE FINISH LINE
HOW MUCH WHAT'S YOUR GUESS.
NOT GONNA GET OUT IN FRONT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
OKAY.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I'M
OBVIOUSLY GOING TO ONE OF WILL
KNOW A LOT OF INFORMATION BEFORE
I AM READY TO VOTE FOR THAT.
AND I THINK MANY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES WILL LIKELY FEEL THE
SAME JUST A GUESS ABSOLUTE.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND GIVE.
WHAT'S THE CURRENT.
WHEN I GO NOW TO ISSUE
?
TWELVE THIS ITEM I THINK IS A
LITTLE LESS CONTROVERSIAL.
IF WE COULD GO TO THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JENNIFER URBAN AND I'M THE CHIEF
OF BUDGETS AND CONTRACTS AT THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE.
THAT'S HE WAS REQUESTING
PERMANENT RESOURCES TO CONTINUE
PERFORMING AUDITS OF HOLDERS TO
ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA UNCLAIMED PROPERTY
LAW WHICH RESULT IN INCREASED
UNCLAIMED PROPERTY TO BE
REUNITED WITH ITS RIGHTFUL OWNER.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN S. HERE RECEIVE SIX
PERMANENT POSITIONS AND ELEVEN
THREE YEAR LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS TO PERFORM AUDITS OF
NON COMPLIANT HOLDERS. ELEVEN
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS IF NOT
APPROVED THROUGH THIS REQUEST
WILL EXPIRE ON JUNE THIRTIETH OF
THIS YEAR.
SINCE FOURTEEN FIFTEEN THE SCO
HAS BEEN APPROVED CONTINUATION
OF THE SAME RESOURCES ON A
LIMITED TERM BASIS.
THROUGH THESE AUDITS SCO HAS
IDENTIFIED AN ANNUAL AVERAGE OF
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS AND
REPORTABLE PROPERTY OVER THE
LAST FIVE YEARS.
IN THE SAME TIME HERE THE
AVERAGE COMPLIANCE RATE IS ABOUT
2%.
THIS WORKLOAD IS ONGOING AND
APPROPRIATELY SUPPORTED WITH
PERMANENT RESOURCES TO ENSURE
HOLDERS CONTINUE TO REPORT AND
REMIT UNCLAIMED PROPERTY. TO SCO
FOR THE ULTIMATE GOAL OF
RETURNING TO THE RIGHTFUL OWNER.
THE RESOURCES WILL ALSO ASSIST
HOLDERS AND CREATING UNCLAIMED
PROPERTY POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
FOR IDENTIFYING AND REPORTING
UNCLAIMED PROPERTY IN SUBSEQUENT
YEARS.
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
WHEN WE GOT OUT TO TO BERMAN
FINANCE?
AIR COVER DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
THE PROPOSAL IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET SUPPORTS THE CONTROLLERS
ONGOING EFFORTS FOR ITS
ADDRESSING HOLDER COMPLIANCE --
AND WE HAVE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME.
HELLO.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THE PROPOSAL IN FRONT OF YOU --
BUT WE DID TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF
A BROADER PERSPECTIVE IN A
REPORT RECENTLY LOOKING AT SOME
OTHER WAYS TO INCREASE HOLDER
COMPLIANCE IN THE PROGRAM.
GIVEN THE SORT OF VAST UNDER
COMPLIANCE RATE OF 2% YOU KNOW
AUDITS ONE IMPORTANT DETERMINANT
DETERRENT -- CAN'T WITH YOU KNOW
A COUPLE DOZEN ON IT'S A YEAR
AND ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES THAT ARE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE.
SO THAT REPORT INTRODUCED TO
DIFFERENT POLICY OPTIONS FOR
RESPONDING TO THIS LOW
COMPLIANCE RATE.
THE FIRST WOULD BE TO REQUIRE
HOLDERS TO REPORT TO FTP IN
THEIR ANNUAL TAX FILINGS JUST
INFORMATIONAL QUESTION ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THEY SUBMITTED A
REPORT TO THE TO THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE IN THE
PREVIOUS YEAR.
THIS WOULD HELP BRING MORE
AWARENESS TO THE PROGRAM AND
THEN THE SECOND WOULD BE TO
PROVIDE A TEMPORARY AMNESTY
PERIOD FOR THOSE HOLDERS THAT
HAVE BEEN NON COMPLIANT IN THE
PAST. TO OFFER THEM A TEMPORARY
PERIOD TO COME FORWARD -- TO
REPORT PASSED YOU UNCLAIMED
PROPERTY AND TO YOU DON'T HAVE A
TEMPORARY -- AMNESTY FROM THE
12% ANNUAL INTEREST PENALTY
THAT'S ASSOCIATED WITH FAILURE
TO COMPLY -- OBVIOUSLY THE MAJOR
GOAL ASSOCIATED WITH THIS WOULD
BE TO REUNITE MORE PEOPLE WITH
THEIR PROPERTY -- BUT THIS WOULD
ALSO HAVE A GENERAL FUND BENEFIT
PERHAPS IN THE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AND ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF
PUBLIC WISH TO COMMENT ON THIS
ITEM.
SO WE ARE GOING TO HOLD THIS
ITEM OPEN.
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION -- I
HAVE BEEN ASKED BY MISTER
NAZARIAN WHO HAS HAD RUN OUT TO
PRESENT ANOTHER BILL TO HOLD.
ISSUE THIRTEEN UNTIL HE'S BACK
SO WE WILL DISCUSS THE ARTS
COUNCIL -- LIKELY IN A FEW
MINUTES IF WE GAVE BILL NOW TO
ISSUE -- FOURTEEN THE CAL ABLE
PROGRAM CALIFORNIA ACHIEVING A
BETTER LIFE EXPERIENCE
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DANTE
ALLEN I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA A BLACKBOARD --
WE ARE HERE TODAY -- WITH A
PROPOSED GENERAL FUND LOAN OF
ONE MILLION SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO CONTINUE AND ARE
IMPLEMENTATION AND OPERATION OF
THE CALIFORNIA ACHIEVING A
BETTER LIFE EXPERIENCE PROGRAM
WHICH IS.
A SAVINGS AND INVESTMENT PROGRAM
THAT OFFERS -- TAX ADVANTAGE
OPTIONS FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES -- IN A WAY THAT
DOES NOT -- HARMER INTERFERE
THEIR QUALIFICATION -- FOR
GOVERNMENT FUNDED BENEFITS.
LET'S MOVE TO DEPART IN FINANCE.
DOMINIC AIR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE HAVE NO CONCERNS.
BELLY UP NO GOOD SENSE -- I
THINK CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT
WE WANT TO SEE THRIVE IN THIS
STATE LET ME ASK THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISH TO COMMENT ON
THE SIDE OF ALSO.
GIVEN THAT I CAN MAKE A MOTION
BY MYSELF -- WHEN WE HAVE ENOUGH
OF A QUORUM WE WILL ASK FOR THIS
TO BE APPROVED AS BUDGETED AND
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION?
IF I COULD ADD -- WE OPENED OUR
DOORS IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SINCE THAT TIME WE'VE.
ACHIEVED A ROBUST ENROLLMENT WE
HAVE ABOUT AS OF YESTERDAY NINE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ACCOUNTS THAT
HAVE BEEN OPENED -- WITH JUST
OVER THREE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN ASSETS UNDER
MANAGEMENT THAT'S FANTASTIC I
THINK WANNA SEE THAT CONTINUE TO
GROW.
THANK YOU THANKS TO WORK.
WHEN WE MOVE NOW TO GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY MOVING TO
ISSUE?
FIFTEEN OFFICE OF DIGITAL
INNOVATION.
WHAT'S THAT BUT IT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I WOULD SAY MEMBERS BEFORE A
LITTLE SHORT.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TO GO AHEAD DEPARTMENT
FINANCE AGAIN -- I'M HERE TO
TALK ABOUT A A MORE.
POSITIVE TECHNOLOGY TOPIC THAN
THAT THE AGENDA YOU HEARD
EARLIER IN REGARDS.
TO A LARGE IT PROJECT
[inaudible]
I'M.
THE GOVERNMENT'S FOR TOO LONG
HAVE NEGLECTED TO THINK ABOUT
THE CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE WHEN
DELIVERING GOVERNMENT SERVICES
AND FUNCTIONS WHETHER IN PERSON
THROUGH THE MAIL OR EVEN ONLINE.
AS WE BROUGHT TECHNOLOGY IN OUR
WORK WITH LARGELY FOCUSED ON
AUTOMATING EXISTING PROCESSES
AND WORK FLOWS BASED ON HOW WE
THINK THINGS SHOULD WORK FAR TOO
OFTEN WE FAIL TO ASK THE PEOPLE
WE SERVE.
HOW THEY WOULD LIKE TO ACCESS
GOVERNMENT SERVICES WHAT'S
HELPFUL TO THEM?
WHAT THEY THINK OF THIS AND AND
WHAT DO THEY THINK THE SERVICES
WE DO PROVIDE?
OUR TECHNOLOGY INVESTMENTS --
HISTORICALLY BEEN.
LARGELY ONE OFF ONE DEPARTMENT
ONE SOLUTION APPROACH IS THAT
ONLY HAPPEN AFTER INDIVIDUAL
DEPARTMENTS COME FORWARD. TO
SOLVE A DEPARTMENTAL NEED AND
WHILE THIS APPROACH IS
ACCEPTABLE IN THE EIGHTIES AND
NINETIES A PERHAPS IN THE TWO
THOUSANDS -- IT'S NO LONGER
VIABLE APPROACH TO MEETING THE
PUBLIC'S EXPECTATIONS.
A RECENT EXPERIENCES SHINED A
SPOTLIGHT ON THIS PROBLEM.
I DON'T THINK I NEED TO REMIND
THE COMMITTEE WHEN I'M TALKING
ABOUT THERE -- TECHNOLOGIES
RELENTLESS ADVANCE HAS RADICALLY
CHANGED A LOT OUR LIVES IN THE
SOCIETY WE LIVE IN FROM HOW AND
WHERE WE GET INFORMATION.
CONDUCTOR FINANCIAL AFFAIRS SHOP
ACCESS ENTERTAINMENT HOW WE
INTERACT WITH ONE ANOTHER THE
WORLD IS A VERY DIFFERENT PLACE
TODAY THAN IT WAS JUST A DECADE
AGO.
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR COMPANIES
COMPETE FOR THE CUSTOMER'S
ATTENTION AND BUSINESS BY THE
LIVING WORLD CLASS USER
EXPERIENCES THEY FOCUS ON THE
CUSTOMER AND SO SHOULD WE SO
THIS PROPOSAL IT'S ABOUT
CHANGING CULTURE.
IT'S ABOUT VALUING INNOVATION.
IT'S ABOUT INVESTING IN OUR
WORKFORCE IT'S ABOUT DELIVERING
GOVERNMENT SERVICES IN A WAY
THAT IS ACCESSIBLE MEANINGFUL
AND INTUITIVE TO THE PUBLIC WE
SERVE.
IT'S ABOUT IMPROVING CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AND IT'S NOT ABOUT
BIG I. T. AND BIG PROJECTS IT'S
ABOUT INNOVATION AND THAT'S A
CLEAR DISTINCTION I WANT ME
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
TECHNOLOGY HERE AS MUCH AS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT INNOVATION AND
SERVICE DELIVERY TO THE PEOPLE
WE SERVE.
THIS PROPOSAL -- IS DIFFERENT
CONCEPTS SUBSTANCE AND EXECUTIVE
SUPPORT THAN ANYTHING WE'VE DONE
IN THE SPACE BEFORE.
AN EXECUTIVE SPONSORSHIP STARTS
AT THE TOP OF THE GOVERNOR
HIMSELF THIS GOVERNOR LITERALLY
STUDY THIS AREA AND WROTE A BOOK
ABOUT IT -- THIS PROPOSAL IS
GENERALLY BASED ON SUCCESSFUL
MODELS ORIGINATING IN THE UNITED
KINGDOM WITH THE GOVERNMENT
DIGITAL SERVICES -- HERE AT HOME
WITH US DIGITAL SERVICES AND
EIGHTEEN F. AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
ANOTHER DIGITAL SERVICE
OPERATIONS OF VARIOUS LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT AROUND THE WORLD.
MOST FOLLOW A SIMILAR WELL
ESTABLISHED PLAYBOOK.
OUR GOALS FOR THIS OFFICER TO
ESTABLISH A CULTURE OF
INNOVATION SOMETHING IT'S VERY
HARD TO DO IN GOVERNMENT --
DRIVE A CUSTOMER CENTRIC MINDSET
OR OTHERWISE KNOWN AS HUMAN
CENTERED DESIGN THAT REALLY
MEANS THINK ABOUT THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE GONNA USE OUR SERVICES
WHEN YOU DESIGN YOUR SERVICES.
BUT TO SOFTEN THEIR ISSUES ASK
THEM.
WE'RE GOING TO FOCUS ON BUSINESS
PROCESS IMPROVEMENT SOMETHING
THE STATUS STRUGGLED ON
HISTORICALLY WE'RE GONNA
UTILIZED AGILE AND OTHER OPEN
APPROACH AS TO HOW WE BUY AND
BUILD THINGS WE'RE GONNA DO
PROTOTYPES BUILD.
TEST ITERATE GET FEEDBACK TESTED
RATE AGAIN SO ON IT'S ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY AND OPEN DATA.
IT'S ABOUT COLLABORATION
SHAREABLE AND REUSABLE SOLUTIONS
AND KNOWLEDGE TRANSFER. TO THAT
END -- THE ADMINISTRATION IS
REQUESTING INITIAL START UP
RESOURCES OF THIRTY SIX POINT
POINT SEVEN THAT'S GENERAL FUND.
FOR TWO POINT SIX MILLION
ONGOING NINE POINT SIX THAT'S
GENERAL FUND AND ABOUT FIFTY
POSITIONS TO ESTABLISH THE
OFFICER DIGITAL INNOVATION
WITHIN THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
AGENCY.
THE OFFICE AS PROPOSED WILL HAVE
AUTHORITY TO DEVELOP AND ENFORCE
REQUIREMENTS FOR DEPARTMENTS TO
ASSESS THEIR SERVICE DELIVERY
METHODS AND MODELS AND
UNDERLYING BUSINESS PROCESSES
FROM A CUSTOMER OR END USER
PERSPECTIVE IN THESE AUTHORITIES
ARE.
DEFINED IN THE CORRESPONDING
TRAILER BILL.
THE KEY PIECES OF THIS PROPOSAL
ONE IS BEYOND THE OFFICE ITSELF
IS THE IS THE CREATION OF
INNOVATION ACADEMY.
AND IN OUR VIEW SUSTAINABLE
INNOVATION REQUIRES A CULTURE OF
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT IT'S A
MINDSET IS NOT JUST WORDS THAT
THAT WE HAVE TO DRIVE THAT
CULTURE CHANGE.
AND THOUGHT AND A THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH TO HUMAN CHANGE
MANAGEMENT AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER THESE ARE TWO AREAS THAT
THE THERE BEEN A PARTICULAR
CHALLENGE FOR GOVERNMENT GENERAL
AND CALIFORNIA'S NO EXCEPTION.
THE OFFICE WILL ADDRESS THESE
NEEDS TO THE CREATION OF A
SCALABLE INNOVATION ACADEMY
FOCUSED ON CONTINUOUS PROCESS
IMPROVEMENT HUMAN CHANGE
MANAGEMENT EXECUTIVE SPONSORSHIP.
AND A CUSTOMER CENTRIC MINDSET.
IN THIS ACADEMY WE ENVISION WILL
BE MANDATORY FOR ALL STATE
SUPERVISORS MANAGERS AND
EXECUTIVES -- WE ALSO INTEND
INVESTED THIS'LL TRAINING IN OUR
I. T. WORK FORCE.
IN AREAS OF AGILE AND OTHER
MODERN DEVELOPMENT PLATFORMS AND
TOOLS IS THIS OFFICE DEVELOPS
INTO FINDS TOOLS IN A PATH
FORWARD FOR DIGITAL STRATEGY FOR
CALIFORNIA.
WE WANT TO TAKE THAT KNOWLEDGE
AND PUSH IT OUT TO OUR STATE IT
WORKFORCE AND INVEST IN THEM SO
THEY BRING THOSE SKILLS AND THAT
VISION TO THEIR DEPARTMENTS AS
WELL.
AND THEN FINALLY.
A KEY PIECE OF THIS PROPOSALS
INNOVATION FUND.
A PROPOSED INCLUDES FUNDING FOR
ONE TIME FUNDING OF TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO ALLOW THE
OFFICE TO ASSIST OTHER
DEPARTMENTS WITH THE TOOLS AND
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO ADDRESS
PRIORITIZE NEEDS.
THIS IS INTENDED TO ALLOW THE
OFFICE MOVED QUICKLY TO ADDRESS
ISSUES AND PROVIDE SOLUTIONS IN
REAL TIME AND THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT AND IMPORTANT CHANGE
FROM THE EXISTING BUDGET AND I.
T..
PROJECT APPROVAL PROCESS SEES
WHICH ADD YEARS TO TIME LINES
SOMETHING WE DISCUSSED EARLIER.
THEY TEND TO LEAD TO LARGE
PROJECT PROPOSALS.
AND ARE CORRESPONDINGLY RISKY
AND COSTLY LARGE SYSTEM
IMPLEMENTATIONS.
WE FULLY KNOWLEDGE THAT
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR ALL THESE FUNDS ARE YOU LIES
WILL BE A CRITICAL TO THE
SUCCESS OF THE OFFICE.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS AND I HAVE IN THAT
AREA.
FINALLY WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THERE
WAS SOME APPARENT OVERLAP WITH
THE PARTNER TECHNOLOGIES
EXISTING OFFICE ADDITIONAL
INNOVATION WHICH IS BEING
RENAMED TO AVOID ANY CONFUSION
GOING FORWARD HOWEVER AT THIS
POINT.
WE'RE NOT THINK THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT -- DUPLICATION
RATHER WE SEE THE OFFICE AND SEE
TIAS HAVING COMPLEMENTARY ROLES --
AND WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE ONLY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION
AND LET ME -- SEE IF I CAN JUST
START AND SET THE TONE THAT I
WANT TO ABOUT THIS FIRST OF ALL
I AM.
VERY APPRECIATIVE THAT GOVERNOR
NEWSOME IS MOVING FORWARD WITH
THIS -- AND JUST FOR THE PUBLIC
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE LET ME JUST READ FROM
SOME OF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTING HIS
OFFICE WILL BE AN AMAZING
CHALLENGES CHALLENGE THAT WILL
REQUIRE INCREDIBLE LEADERSHIP
FROM THE NEW ADMINISTRATION.
SIMILAR APPROACHES HAVE BEEN
TRIED BEFORE LEFT THE STATE WITH
COSTS THE LEGACIES OF FELL
PROJECTS YEARS ADRIFT IN A
CULTURE THAT A SPURNED
INVESTMENT IN TECHNOLOGY.
I. T. PROJECTS FAIL IN
SACRAMENTO BECAUSE OF A LACK OF
OWNERSHIP GOVERNANCE WERE
TRAINING.
IN ONE PUBLICATION WAS ESTIMATED
60% OF ALL IT PROJECTS FAIL AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE UP AGAINST AND
I THINK IT WAS -- APPROPRIATE
THAT WE HAD THE ITEM AROUND
FISCAL JUST A FEW ITEMS AGO
BECAUSE THAT.
TELLS YOU WHAT YOU'RE UP AGAINST.
IN MY PERSPECTIVE IS -- THE
VISION IS FANTASTIC AND THE
DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS RIGHT AND
THERE DON'T SEEM TO BE A LOT OF
DETAILS ON HOW THIS IS GONNA BE
CARRIED OUT SO MY QUESTIONS
REALLY.
ARE JUST TRYING TO DRILL DOWN A
LITTLE BIT ON QUESTIONS ARE
RAISED IN THE COMMITTEE AND ALSO
SOME QUESTIONS THAT WE ALL HAVE --
THIS IS FOCUSED ON REALLY AN
AGILE.
APPROACH AN AGILE PROCUREMENT
APPROACH -- BUT OBVIOUSLY OUR
STATE HASN'T REALLY HAD THAT
SKILL SET OR THAT EXPERTISE AND
WONDERING HOW YOU PLAN TO BRING
THAT IN QUICKLY -- I THINK
RELATED TO THAT -- THEIR
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW WE GROW THIS
PROJECT OVER TIME AND WONDER IF
YOU CAN JUST GIVE US A SENSE OF
WHAT YOUR EXPECTATIONS ARE
AROUND HELD BASS THIS OFFICE MY
GROW -- AND THEN CLEARLY WE ALSO
KNOW THAT -- STATE WORKERS AND
BY AND BY THE STATE
BUREAUCRACIES WILL BE CRITICAL
TO MAKING THIS HAPPEN AND
THERE'S ALWAYS BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT TENSION WITH OUTSIDE
TECH VENDORS WERE POINTED THE
FINGER AT STATE BUREAUCRATS WILL
POINT FINGERS BACK AT TECHNOLOGY
WORKERS.
CAN YOU GIVE US A SENSE OF HOW
YOU PLAN TO MANAGE.
THE PAST TENSIONS AND AND MOVE
IT INTO MORE POSITIVE FUTURE
SURE FOR FIRST LET ME START BY
BY -- RESTATING THIS IS NOT
ABOUT TECHNOLOGY THIS IS NOT
ABOUT INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
PROJECTS THIS IS ABOUT SERVICE
DELIVERY MUCH OF WHAT'S GOING TO
IS GOING TO HAPPEN IN THE
DIGITAL SPACE THAT'S WHERE
SOCIETY IS TODAY.
SO SO DON'T THINK OF THIS IN
TERMS OF BUYING OR BUILDING BIG
STATE IT PROJECTS IT'S ABOUT
FOCUSING ON SERVICE DELIVERY HOW
WE DELIVER SERVICES TO CUSTOMERS
WHERE THE PAIN POINTS FOR THE
PEOPLE TO HAVE TO DO BUSINESS
WITH THE GOVERNMENT HOW TO MAKE
LIFE EASIER FOR THEM HOW.
CAN WE MAKE THE PROCESS MORE
INTUITIVE EASIER UBIQUITOUS TO A
JUST LIKE THEIR LIVES ARE TODAY
WITH MOBILE PHONES AND COMPUTERS
AND AND PORTABLE DEVICES THEY
THERE THERE IS VIRTUALLY NO
LIMIT ON YOUR PERSONAL LIFE AND
HOW YOU INTERACT WITH.
BUSINESSES AND YOUR FRIENDS AND
FAMILY AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
EXCEPT THAT WHEN YOU GET TO THE
STATE LEVEL THE THE STATE FORCES
YOU INTO NINETEEN SIXTIES AND
SEVENTIES BUSINESS PROCESSES.
MANY OF WHICH HAVE BEEN
AUTOMATED AND PUT ON A WEB AND
THEY'RE NOT VERY INTUITIVE THEY
DON'T HAVE FULL FUNCTIONALITY
THEY DON'T PROVIDE INFORMATION
THEY DON'T HAVE OPEN DATA.
THAT THERE'S A THERE'S A LOT A
LOT OF BAD OUT THERE AND LOT OF
PROBLEMS ARE TRYING TO SOLVE.
AND BUT THIS IS ABOUT A TARGETED
EFFORT TO TO FOCUS ON THE
DELIVERY OF GOVERNMENT SERVICES
TO THE PEOPLE WE SERVE AND THIS
MODEL HAS BEEN DONE SUCCESSFULLY
AROUND THE GLOBE SO WE'RE NOT
INVENTING SOMETHING NEW HERE WE
ARE IN FACT TAKING.
A GOVERNMENT LED MODEL THAT --
WAS VERY SUCCESSFUL IN EUROPE
HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL UNITED STATES HAS
BEEN SUCCESSFUL AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL IN OTHER PLACES AND WE'RE
SIMPLY SAYING.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT WEEK WE GET
BEAT UP WHEN THINGS GO BAD WE WE
RIGHTFULLY ARE TAKING OUR LUMPS
OVER WHAT'S HAPPENING AT DMB.
AND AND AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FIX THAT THIS IS A MORE SYSTEMIC
APPROACH TO FIXING THOSE THINGS
PROACTIVELY AS OPPOSED TO FIXING
REACTIVE WE WANT SOMETHING BLOWS
UP.
SO I I WOULD I WOULD I WOULD ASK
THAT WE LOOK AT THIS THROUGH THE
LENS OF SERVICE DELIVERY AND NOT
LINK IT NECESSARILY TO OUR
HISTORY WITH BIG IT PROJECTS
BECAUSE NOTHING WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE IS ABOUT THE GUY TO
PROSECUTE YOU GIVE.
ANY EXAMPLES OF WHAT YOUR VISION.
WHAT ON WHAT LIKE IN WHAT
CONTEXT?
ANY CONTEXT WHAT WHAT WHAT ARE
YOU GONNA TACKLE FILM SO SO
WE'VE WE'VE IDENTIFIED A COUPLE
OF OF PRELIMINARY TARGET
OPPORTUNITY.
PARCHMENTS DEPARTMENT MOTOR
VEHICLES BEING.
ONE WHERE -- IT'S RIGHT FOR AN
ENTIRE REVISIT OF HOW THEY HOW
THEY SERVE THE PUBLIC AND WE'VE
LOOKED AT AND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
IN THE LICENSING FUNCTIONS THAT
THE PARTNER CONSUMER AFFAIRS
WHICH HAS BEEN A CONSTANT
STRUGGLE -- AS THEIR STARTING
POINTS BUT WE'RE ALSO ALONG WITH
THIS IS IS THE THE BUILDING OF
THE BIT ACADEMY IN DELIVERING
THE TRAINING TO HELP DRIVE THE
CULTURAL CHANGE THE DRIVE THAT
MINDSET CHANGE.
AND THEN WITH THE INNOVATION
FUND AND THE DEPARTMENT THE
OFFICE BEING ABLE TO GO OUT AND
LEAD DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS ON A
PARTY BASIS FOR DEPARTMENTS
MAYBE IT'S BUILDING A NEW APP
MAYBE IT'S REDESIGNING -- THE
WAY YOU REGISTER OR RENEW YOUR
VEHICLE REGISTRATION -- AND
BRINGING THAT TO BRING THAT TO
BEAR TO THE PUBLIC AS A NEW
INNOVATIVE SERVICE AND THEN THE
THINGS WE'VE LEARNED ALONG THE
WAY DOING THAT WE WILL THEN HAND
OFF TO OTHER DEPARTMENTS WHO
HAVE SIMILAR BUSINESS PROCESS
NEEDS. TO TO TAKE IT TO SCALE
AND APPLIED ACROSS EXECUTIVE
BRANCH COULD YOU GIVE US SOME
EXAMPLES OF WHERE THIS IS WORK
ELSEWHERE AND I YOU ALLUDED TO
THEM BUT YEAH IN IT THAT'S
WORKED IN GREAT BRITAIN -- THEY
HAVE THERE'S THERE'S A TON OF
MATERIAL OUT THERE ABOUT THE
SUCCESSES -- THE PROJECTS
THEY'VE DONE AND HOW VALUABLE
SPEND AND THEY STARTED.
IN ENGLAND WITH -- ALL THEIR
VARIOUS WEB DOMAINS IT WAS IT
WAS A A MISMATCH ACROSS THE YOU
KNOW THE UNITED KINGDOM AND
THERE'S HUNDRED IF I GOT MY
WEBSITES THEY THEY WERE ABLE TO
BRING ALL THAT INTO A SINGLE
PLATFORM.
AND A SINGLE PORTAL FOR THE
CITIZENS OF THE U. K. TO ACCESS
GOVERNMENT SERVICES AND
FUNCTIONS.
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL IN THE
UNITED STATES -- US DENTAL
SERVICES DID SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK TO IN CALIFORNIA
AND THEY DID -- LOG IN DOT GOV
WHICH IS A SORT OF US.
IDENTITY MANAGEMENT FEATURE FOR
US CITIZENS ACCESSING CERTAIN
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS IN A BILL
DIDN'T HAVE NOW EXTENDED THAT
SAME FUNCTIONALITY THAT CITY
BUILT IN SUCH A WAY THAT THEY
CAN EASILY LINK IT TO OTHER
DEPARTMENTS TO HAVE SOMEWHERE
IDENTITY MANAGEMENT IS A NEVER
ROLLED OUT ACROSS A NUMBER OF
AGENCIES.
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND THERE'S
THERE THERE'S THERE'S A TON OF
OF INFORMATION OUT THERE ABOUT
THE GOOD WORK BEING DONE IN THE
SPACE AROUND THE WORLD.
AND GIVEN YOU YOU YOU POINTED TO
TWO DEPARTMENTS THAT HAVE
HISTORICALLY ABSOLUTELY OBJECT
WE FAILED AT THINK ABOUT THE USE
OF IT DMV AND THE PARTY CONSUMER
SERVICES.
DCA WHAT'S WHAT'S THE THINKING
ON WHAT YOU WOULD DO NEXT GIVEN
THE YEARS OF CHALLENGES.
IN ALTON SENSES FIRST IT'S
STARTING WITH THAT.
SHIP THEM PERSPECTIVE AND THAT
IS A CUSTOMER.
FOCUSED.
BUSINESS PROCESS DELIVERY SO
THINK ABOUT ALL THE LINES OF
BUSINESS YOU DO.
AND WHO HAS TO INTERACT WITH YOU
AND AND HOW THEY CAN INTERACT
WITH YOU.
AND SO A DMV IT'S IT'S RIGHT FOR
REINVENTION.
YOU KNOW WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OF COURSE
THE GOVERNOR'S ASSIGNED US A
STRIKE TEAM TO GO IN THERE AND
AND ISSUE SOME PRELIMINARY.
INFORMATION ON THAT WE ALSO HAVE
AN AUDIT -- AND A TECHNOLOGY
REVIEW HAPPENING AT THE SAME
TIME ALL OF THOSE THINGS COULD
BE USED TO INFORM ON A PRIORITY
BASIS.
WHERE THE BEST VALUE IS AS FAR
AS MEETING CUSTOMER EXPECTATIONS
AND AND WHAT?
BUSINESS PROCESS AND SERVICE
DELIVERY FOCUS ON FIRST AT THE
DMV.
AND ANOTHER LOT OF FOLKS HERE
FOR OTHER ITEMS SO -- ONE AND I
SUGGEST I BE I'D LIKE TO LEARN A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT WHAT YOU
GUYS ARE THINKING PARTICULAR
LOVE TO SEE EXAMPLES THAT YOU'RE
CONSIDERING FROM OTHER PLACES
AND WHAT YOU MIGHT.
DO TO BRING IT HERE BOTH OF
THOSE DEPARTMENTS ARE ONES THAT
I THINK ARE -- ACUTELY -- OF
INTEREST FOR MANY OF US IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
IT SEEMS LIKE EVERY WEEK -- OUR
OFFICE GETS A COMPLAINT FROM YET
ANOTHER CONSTITUENT WHOSE BODY
THEIR HEAD UP.
INVOLVING ANOTHER BUREAU UNDER
THE CA A AND THEN THE DMV IS
JUST AN ON GOING -- SET OF
CHALLENGES ABSOLUTELY WE WE HEAR
IT TOO WE WE HEAR IT ALMOST
EVERY DAY AND HAPPY TO TO WORK
WITH YOU IN YOUR OFFICE AND AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF -- AND
PROVIDE ANY DEATHS AND ALL
INFORMATION YOU WOULD LIKE AS WE
GO THROUGH THIS PROCESS ONE
FINAL QUESTION WHEN DO YOU
EXPECT THE DMV TO ACCEPT CREDIT
CARDS -- MORE TO COME -- COME ON
GIVE US SOME HOPE.
THE PART OF FINANCE -- I'M SORRY.
YEAH I JUST WANT TO MENTION WE
DID PUBLISH A BUDGET AND POLICY
POSTS ON THIS ISSUE AND RAISE
SOME ISSUES FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION I WON'T GO THROUGH
ALL OF THEM -- BUT JUST WANNA
KINDA CATEGORIZE THEM FOR YOU --
SO THE FIRST OF THOSE BEING KIND
OF THE LEGISLATURE'S ROLE
RELATIVE TO THIS NEW OFFICE --
PARTICULARLY AROUND THE CRITERIA
THAT IS USED TO SELECT THE
RELATIVE ENGAGEMENTS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE -- PROPOSED FOR THE
OFFICE OF DIGITAL INNOVATION AND
KIND OF SETTING LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES FOR THOSE -- AS WELL
AS THE CONSIDERATION APPROVAL IN
OVERSIGHT OF THOSE PROJECTS --
THAT ARE GOING TO BE FUNDED WITH
THIS TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME FUNDING -- THE SECOND
OF WHICH IS AGAIN THIS ISSUE
AROUND DUPLICATION OF EFFORT
ACROSS CDT AND THE OFFICE OF
DIGITAL INNOVATION AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT THERE ARE CITY STAFF.
OR BUDGETARY RESOURCES THAT ARE
DUPLICATIVE -- IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION INTENDS TO LEAVE
THOSE RESOURCES WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY -- TO
THE EXTENT THAT'S HAPPENING TO
BE IMPORTANT TO KNOW WHETHER --
THAT WILL BE THE CASE AND
WHETHER OR NOT IT COULD
POTENTIALLY BE REVERTED BACK TO
THE STATE -- AND FINALLY AS YOU
MENTIONED KIND OF THE ISSUE
AROUND ONGOING FUNDING OF
POSITIONS FOR THE OFFICE --
PARTICULARLY OUTLINING THE
TIMELINE FOR HIRING FOLKS -- AND
BRINGING THEM ON BOARD TO KIND
OF STUFF THE OFFICE SO WITH THAT
I'LL LEAVE IT THERE.
AND LET ME ASK THEIR MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THE WISH TO COMMENT. ONE
FINAL QUESTION I'M ASSUMING YOUR
HOPE IS TO BRING BEST AND
BRIGHTEST FROM.
INNOVATIVE TECH SECTORS INTO
GOVERNMENTS -- GIVE US A SENSE
OF HOW THOSE INDIVIDUALS WILL BE
INTERACTING WITH.
RANK AND FILE FOLKS WHO HAVE FOR
DECADES BEEN DOING THINGS
DIFFERENTLY AND HOW YOU.
SEE THAT CHANGING OF THE CULTURE.
SO WHAT WHEN WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THESE MODELS THEY THAT -- HAVE
BEEN DEPLOYED SUCCESSFULLY OTHER
PLACES THAT THEY THEY THEY BRING
SORT OF A BLENDED APPROACH THEY
BRING TECHNICAL EXPERTS IN FROM
OUTSIDE PEOPLE WANT TO COME DO A
STINT IN PUBLIC SERVICE THAT
WANTED SPEND A YEAR TO WORKING
ON YOU KNOW SOMETHING FOR THE
GREATER PUBLIC GOOD.
THEY CAN COME FROM THE OUTSIDE
THEY CAN ALSO COME FROM WITHIN
GOVERNMENT AND SO WE WE HAVE AN
I. T. WORK FORCE OF AROUND
ELEVEN THOUSAND I. T. EMPLOYEES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S SORT OF FULL TIME
EQUIVALENTS WE HAVE TENS OF
THOUSANDS ON OUR HIRING
ELIGIBILITY LIST SO WE HAVE WE
HAVE A DEPTH OF IN HOUSE TALENT
AS WELL -- AND SO WE SEE IT AS A
BLEND PEOPLE COMING IN
AUGMENTING OUR IN HOUSE DON'T
BRING FRESH PERSPECTIVES WORKING
A PROJECT TO TO AND ROLLING BACK
OUT -- AS WELL AS IS WE DO
PROJECTS WITH DEPARTMENTS
THERE'S GOING TO BE A NATURAL A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STAFF AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF THIS GOING TO
TRANSFER KNOWLEDGE IT HAPPENS IN
REAL TIME AS WE'RE DOING THIS
PROJECTS WITH APARTMENTS.
AS I SAID AT THE TOP OF ABIG
PIECES ABOUT INVESTING IN OUR
WORK FORCE AND THAT AND THEIR
SKILLS AND TOOLS THEY HAVE.
GREAT WELL -- YOU HAVE A LOT OF
WORKING FOR ANY -- OBVIOUSLY
VERY VERY INTERESTED IN SEEING
HOW IT APPLIES -- I'VE HAD.
QUITE A NUMBER OF CONVERSATIONS
WITH.
THEN LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR NOW
GOVERNOR NEWSOME ON THIS VERY
TOPIC AND AND LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING.
UPDATES ON YOUR HOPEFUL
SUCCESSES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
WHEN WE MOVE TO THE NEXT ITEM?
TWO ITEMS RELATED TO THE CENSUS
STICK UP ISSUE SIXTEEN TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS OUTREACH
.
DO THIS FOR YOU AND KID HOW ARE
YOU.
PLACE YOU CAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- THANK YOU
FOR INVITING ME 2% ON THE SET
THE TWENTY TWENTY OUTREACH
EFFORTS I'M DOES COULD TALKING
AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMPLETE COUNT. TO
TWENTY TWENTY OFFICE.
THE JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL
INCLUDED FIFTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLAR ALLOCATION TO AUGMENT
ACTIVITIES BY THE CENSUS OFFICE
TO FURTHER ENHANCE THE EFFORTS
CURRENTLY UNDER WAY TO ENSURE A
FULL AND COMPLETE COUNT OF THE
ENTIRE STATE'S POPULATION.
THE MAJORITY OF THIS FUNDING
WILL BE DEDICATED TO OUR
OUTREACH EFFORTS THE FOCUS ON
THE HARDEST ACCOUNT.
OR THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY UNDER COUNTED IN
THE CENSUS.
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY MILLION
WOULD BE PROVIDED TO AUGMENT
OUTREACH EFFORTS BY COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS HELLO WELL
AS THE OUTREACH AND PUBLIC
RELATIONS CAMPAIGN CONTRACTORS.
SPECIFICALLY OUR REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATIVE COMMITTEE BASED
ORGANIZATIONS.
WOULD RECEIVE SUPPORT FOR THE
NON RESPONSE FOLLOW UP PERIOD
WHICH BEGINS APRIL TWENTY TWENTY
AND CONTINUES THROUGH LATE JULY
OF TWENTY TWENTY THE ORIGINAL
ALLOCATION WAS TWENTY TWO POINT
NINE FIVE MILLION.
AND THAT WOULD BE AUGMENTED BY
TEN MILLION TO REACH COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE A LOW RESPONSE RATE.
TOWARD THE END OF THE
ENUMERATION PERIOD.
STATEWIDE CBO'S WILL HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL WARD OPPORTUNITIES
FOR WARTS TO FILL THE GAPS AND
BE RESPONSIVE TO AREAS THAT NEED
FURTHER OUT REACH.
THE CURRENT BUDGET FOR THE
STATEWIDE CBO'S INCLUDED FOUR
POINT ZERO FIVE MILLION THAT
WILL BE AUGMENTED BY
APPROXIMATELY ANOTHER SIX
MILLION OR FIVE POINT NINE FIVE
MILLION. FOR FURTHER TARGETED
OUTREACH TO THOSE HARD TO COUNT
DEMOGRAPHIC POPULATIONS.
IN ADDITION THE OUTREACH AND
PUBLIC RELATIONS OR MEDIA
CAMPAIGN WILL BE AUGMENTED BY
THIRTY MILLION TO ACHIEVE A
STATE WIDE AWARENESS CAMPAIGN
THAT IS MULTI LINGUAL CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE AND ENGAGES LOCAL
ETHNIC MEDIA TO BUILD OUR BASE
OF TRUSTED MESSENGERS.
IN SOME THIS BRINGS THE TOTAL
OUT REACH FUNDING BETWEEN THE
CURRENT AND NEXT FISCAL YEAR TWO
ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLAR STATEWIDE.
IN ADDITION TO THE FIFTY MILLION
FOR OUTREACH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING AND POPULATION SAMPLE
ENUMERATION IS ALSO INCLUDED IN
THIS PROPOSED BUDGET ITEM.
IT PROPOSED TO SUPPORT WE CALL
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING AND
POPULATION SAMPLE ENUMERATION I
CALL IT GYPSY FOR SUPPORT
BECAUSE IT'S KIND OF FOR SHORT
IT'S KIND OF A MOUTH FULL.
WHICH IS THE STUDY BEING CREATED
BY CONDUCTED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCES DEMOGRAPHIC RESEARCH
UNIT.
THE STUDY WILL PROVIDE SEVERAL
IMPORTANT DATA SETS FOLLOWING
THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS.
THIS INCLUDES HELPING TO
IDENTIFY HOW SUCCESSFUL WE WERE
IN ACHIEVING A FULL AND COMPLETE
COUNT.
WHAT BARRIERS EXISTED THAT
BLOCKED OUT REACH FOR BEING
SUCCESSFUL?
AND HOW CAN WE BEST PREPARE FOR
THE TWENTY THIRTY CENSUS.
THIS LAST POINT IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THE CENSUS OFFICE IS
WORKING DILIGENTLY NOT ONLY TO
ACHIEVE A SUCCESSFUL CENSUS
COUNT.
FOR TWENTY TWENTY WE'RE ALSO
WORKING TO ESTABLISH A WELL
DOCUMENTED REPEATABLE OPERATION
AND STRATEGY THAT WILL SERVE THE
STATE AGAIN FOR THE TWENTY
THIRTY CENSUS.
THIS WILL SAVE TIME AND
RESOURCES FOR ONE PREPARATION
FOR THE NEXT CYCLE BEGINS.
WITH THAT WE ARE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
OF MASTER BERMAN FINANCE.
THANK YOU IMAGE I'M WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I JUST
WANNA SAY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZES THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF AN
ACCURATE AND COMPLETE CENSUS
COUNT FOR CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS.
AND FOR THIS REASON THE BUDGET
INCLUDES ADDITIONAL FUNDING --
FOR STATEWIDE OUTREACH EFFORTS
RELATED TO INCREASING THAT PART
PARTICIPATION RATE.
I HOPEWE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS AT THE PROPOSAL AND WE
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THAT'S
CONSISTENT WITH PAST --
LEGISLATIVE ACTION IN THIS AREA.
BEFORE WE GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT
L. JUST TO STAY MY PERSPECTIVE
WHICH IS -- FIRST WANT TO THANK
THOSE OF YOU WHO IN WORKING WITH
AND STATE GOVERNMENT UNDER
GOVERNOR BROWN ON THE CENSUS AND
I KNOW LAST YEAR I AND OTHERS
PUSH FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING WHEN
IT CAME TO THE CENSUS -- I HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN OF THE PERSPECTIVE
THAT WE ARE STILL WOEFULLY SHORT
WHEN IT COMES TO TO OUT REACH --
OFTENTIMES THOSE OF US WHO ARE
ELECTED OFFICE.
GENERAL THERE'S MANY MANY MANY
TIMES THIS TO REACH OUT TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS JUST EDUCATE THEM
ON ONE ELECTION.
AND HERE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT --
SOMETHING THAT IS OF A OF A
MAGNITUDE OF WHAT'S AT STAKE SO
MUCH GREATER THAN ANY INDIVIDUAL
ACTION AND SO.
I CERTAINLY SUPPORT I KNOW A
CALL FOR MORE FUNDING AROUND OUT
REGIONAL JUST MENTION THAT WHEN
I WAS THE PRESIDENT OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
WORKING WITH THEN MAYOR GAVIN
NEWSOM -- WE INVESTED
SIGNIFICANT SAN FRANCISCO
DOLLARS INTO HOW TO HARD TO
REACH POPULATIONS INVESTING
SPECIFICALLY AN OUT REACH.
AND WE WERE THE ONE MAJOR COUNTY
AS YOU KNOW THAT DID NOT SEE A
REAL DROP IN ARE HARD TO REACH --
POPULATIONS WHEN IT CAME TO THAT
CENSUS. TWENTY TEN AND SO IT'S
MY PERSPECTIVE WE WE NEED TO
DOUBLE DOWN -- BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT EVERY DOLLAR WE INVEST
TODAY WILL MEAN LITERALLY MANY
MANY TIMES THAT AS FAR AS
FEDERAL FUNDING WE CAN RECEIVE
AND OTHER BENEFITS THE STATE
COULD RECEIVE.
RELATED TO CENSUS I ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE HAS BEEN A
REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL MEDIA
OUTREACH -- WHICH IS SOMETHING
THAT I WOULD ALSO SUPPORT GIVEN
THE DIVERSITY OF OUR STATE GIVEN
THE CHALLENGES OF COMMUNICATING
AND GIVEN THE SUCCESSES THAT WE
SAW WHEN IT CAME TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ACA.
AND MEDICAL EXPANSION I THINK
THAT WOULD BE AN APPROPRIATE
CONVERSATION.
WE'RE NOT GONNA HAVE A SPECIFIC
CONVERSATION TODAY ABOUT HOW
MUCH WE THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE.
TO INCREASE THE OUT REACH BUDGET
OR THE MEDIA OUTRAGE BUDGET BUT
SUFFICE IT TO SAY.
THIS IS AN AREA THAT I WOULD
SUPPORT AND JUST A TIE FOR
MEMBERS THE AUDIENCE WHO'VE BEEN
HERE LISTENING TO ITEMS AROUND
HOW MUCH WE SPENT ON IT.
IF WE TOOK A MERE FRACTION OF
WHAT WE WASTED IN I. T. O. FOR
MANY MANY YEARS AND DEVOTED IT
HERE.
OR IN OTHER AREAS WE WOULD BE
FAR BETTER OFF AS A STATE FAR
BETTER OFF PHYSICALLY -- AND I
THINK FOR STRONGER AS A AS A AS
AS A CALIFORNIA SO I APPRECIATE
THE PRESENTATION.
LET'S NOT OPEN IT UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT.
HI MY NAME IS ARE TO OCCUR MONA
AND I AM A REPRESENTATIVE OF IN
BUT A MEDIA THAT OWNS -- TO
PROPERTIES HERE IN.
CALIFORNIA LOW PIGNON AND LOOK
BEYOND IN THE BAY AREA -- FIRST
OF ALL WANNA REALLY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS MISTER CHAIR I
THINK THAT YOUR KNOWLEDGE ON THE
OUR REACH NEEDED -- FOR THIS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT PROCESS
AROUND THE CENSUS IS
FUNDAMENTALLY IMPORTANT
PARTICULARLY AS IT RELATES TO
HOW TO CONNECT WITH OUR DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES -- IN LANGUAGE
COMMUNITIES AND THERE'S NO
BETTER WAY THAN USING.
THE MEDIA PARTICULARLY ETHNIC
MEDIA UP AND DOWN THE STATE IN
RURAL URBAN -- DIFFERENT AREAS
AROUND THE STATE -- AND SO -- I
AM HERE REPRESENTING A NUMBER OF
COALITION PARTNERS INCLUDING
MEMBERS THAT ARE NOT HERE TO THE
MOON THOUGH -- IF THINK MEDIA
SERVICE A NUMBER OF OTHERS
REALLY ALL UNIFIED WITH A
MESSAGE THAT -- THIS ADDITIONAL
ALLOTMENT OF RESOURCES FOR OUR
REACH AROUND ETHNIC MEDIA
REACHES IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT --
AS YOU LOOK AT AN INDEPENDENT
STUDY COMMISSIONED BY -- COUPLE
PHILANTHROPIC ORGANIZATIONS IN
THE STATE-- WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE THE OUTRAGE DONE BY THE?
AT THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT A
NUMBER OF OTHERS YOU REALLY ARE
LOOKING AROUND TWENTY DOLLARS --
PER PERSON WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
HEART TO COUNT POPULATION THAT
REALLY SUMS UP -- TO I NEEDED IT --
BASS LINE OUR REACH SOME ABOUT
FIFTY THREE MILLION I THINK THAT
THE PROPOSED BUDGET FOR THE
GOVERNOR GETS US TO ABOUT FORTY
SIX MILLION VERY CLOSE. TO TO
WHAT WE NEED - SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND LOOKING AT
THIS ISSUE I KNOW THERE'S GONNA
BE SUBSEQUENT CONVERSATIONS WE
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT I THINK
THE LOOKING AT THE MODEL OF THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT IS
FUNDAMENTAL.
BECAUSE IT SET A BASELINE OF
WHAT A GOOD AND EFFICIENT
OUTREACH PROGRAM CAN DO WHEN YOU
REALLY.
NOT ONLY DO TRADITIONAL ALL
REACH WITH -- COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS BUT ALSO ENGAGE
THE MEDIA'S PARTNERS AND AS AS
REAL PLAYERS IN THIS EFFORT SO
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND WE LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER.
I WON'T REPEAT WHAT.
I WILL REPEAT WITH MY COLLEAGUES
SAID BUT MY NAME'S REGINA WILL
SEND WITH CALIFORNIA BLACK MEDIA
AND I JUST WANT TO ECHO HIS SAME
SENTIMENTS THAT YOU KNOW THEY
DIGITAL INVESTMENTS WOULD BE --
GREATLY NEEDED AND ENSURING THATTHE AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
ALSO IN PARTICULAR ON IS ON YOU
KNOW.
EQUIPPED WITH THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO MAKE SURE THAT --
WHILE LANGUAGE MAY NOT BE THE
ISSUE -- DEFINITELY A LACK OF
FAITH IN THE SYSTEM IS PARTIALLY
THE ISSUE IN THAT EDUCATION
AROUND IT ON IS GOING TO BE
DEFINITELY NECESSARY SO THAT WE
HAD A MORE AN ACCURATE COUNT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR -- COMMITTEE
MEMBER AND THINK YOU THE DETAILS
FOR CONTINUE TO WORK MY NAME IS --
JUSTIFIED I'M -- IN BOTH MEMBER
OF THE PHONE OFF THE NATION IN
SOUTHERN ARIZONA AND ALSO
CHICANO -- THE STATE WHITE
CENSUS CORNER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE -- PROJECT --
WE'VE BEEN DEEPLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE TRIBAL -- HELLO
CATIONS ARE ONLY THREE HUNDRED
SIXTEEN THOUSAND OF THE ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR MILLION HAVE
BEEN SET ASIDE FOR TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES HERE IN CALIFORNIA --
TO MAKE THEM WANT TO MAKE THINGS
MORE CHALLENGING -- FORTY TRIBES
OF THE ONE HUNDRED AND NINE
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES IN
THE STATE ARE SET TO RECEIVE A
ZERO DOLLARS FOR TWENTY TWENTIES
AFTER TWENTY TWENTY SENDS OUT
REACH -- THERE'S STILL TIME TO
CORRECT THIS ARE WE'RE PROPOSING
HER WE ASK -- 44100% INCREASE IN
FUNDING FOR FOR EVERY TRY
PAIRING CALIFORNIA.
AND A MINIMUM OF FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS -- PER TRIED TO FOR THEM
TO CONDUCT A CENSUS OUT REACH
WITHIN THEIR NATIVE COMMUNITIES --
REGARDLESS OF THEIR TRIBAL
POPULATION SIZE -- LET'S WORK
TOGETHER -- WE CAN'T AFFORD TO
SIT BACK AND WATCH THE POTENTIAL --
SYMBOLIC YOU RAISE OR
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLES THANK
YOU.
EXPECT A PLACE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE MY NAME IS MICHAEL
AND SALAS WE ARE.
I'M WITH THEY'LL BE AYE MEDIA
ALSO KNOWN AS THE BERMAN
BROADCASTING WE ARE THE THIRD
LARGEST SPANISH LANGUAGE
BROADCASTING COMPANY IN THE
UNITED STATES.
PROUDLY CALIFORNIAN BASED IN
BURBANK -- WE SERVE PRIMARILY
THE HISPANIC COMMUNITY AND OF
COURSE THE IMMIGRANT -- SPANISH
LANGUAGE SPEAKING COMMUNITIES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE
HERE TO ASK YOU TO PLEASE
APPROVE THE INCREASE IN FUNDING
FOR CENSUS MEDIA OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION. FOR HARD TO COME
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE AT OB I
MEDIA WE ARE ACUTELY AWARE OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF SECURING AN
ACCURATE COUNT FOR OUR GREAT
STATE AND WHAT'S AT STAKE OUT A
STATE AND NATIONAL LEVEL.
LIKE MY COLLEAGUES HERE TODAY WE
ARE COMMITTED TO AMPLIFYING THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA'S MESSAGE ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF CENSUS
PARTICIPATION.
AND WILL USE ALL OF OUR MEDIA
PLATFORMS AND RESOURCES TO
ENSURE HARD ACCOUNT COMMUNITIES
ARE INCLUDED BY EXTENSIVE PUBLIC
AWARENESS MEDIA CAMPAIGNS
LEADING UP TO THE CENSUS TWENTY
TWENTY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
NEXT WEEK.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR US CBO OUT REACH FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS -- AND
FOR BRINGING THIS ISSUE TO THE
FLOOR TODAY.
MY NAME IS A SPENT ON LIKE ABOUT
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF CHIRLA
STATEWIDE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION AS WELL AS A
TRUSTED MESSENGER WITH NATIONAL
IMPACT FOUNDED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX TO ADVANCE TO PROTECT
THE CIVIL RIGHTS OF IMMIGRANTS
AND REFUGEES.
WE APPRECIATE AGAIN THE
COMMITMENT OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO ACHIEVING AN ACCURATE
CENSUS COUNT.
AND OF THE CALIFORNIA COMPLETE
COUNT COMMITTEE OTHER STAFF WE
APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR'S
ADDITIONAL ALLOCATION OF FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR A STATE WHITE OUT REACHING
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET WE'RE ALSO PLEASED
TO READ TO HEAR THAT THE CUP
CALIFORNIA COMPLETE COUNT
COMMITTEE INTENDS TO ALLOCATE.
FIFTEEN POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS TO CBO OUT REACH NEVER
THE LESS WE WE ALONG WITH OUR
PARTNERS IN THE CENSUS POLICY
ADVOCACY NETWORK SEE PAN.
BELIEVE THAT THIS FUNDING STILL
FALLS VERY SHORT WE'RE FACING
FEDERAL POLICIES INCLUDING.
ANTI IMMIGRATION RHETORIC THAT
HAVE GENERATED FEAR AMONG OUR
COMMUNITIES AT THAT WERE ALREADY
LESS LIKELY THAN OTHERS TO
COMPLETE THE SENSES.
AS I WAS TELLING MY OWN MOTHER
ABOUT.
MY WORK ON THE CENSUS WHICH LET
SHE AN IMMIGRANT FROM MEXICO WHO
WAS PREVIOUSLY AT UNDOCUMENTED.
ADMITTED TO ME THAT SHE HAD A
FILLED OUT THE SENSES IN.
TWENTY TEN AND MY PARENTS HAVE
BEEN IN THIS COUNTRY NOW FOR
OVERTHREE DECADES HAVE ONLY
RECEIVED THIS FOR MAYBE ONCE OR
TWICE.
SHE HAD NO IDEA WHAT THIS FORM
WAS OR BY THE GOVERNMENT WAS
ASKING -- WHAT WAS ASKING FOR US
TO PROVIDE THIS SENSITIVE
INFORMATION?
AND TO BE HONEST YOU SIMPLY
DIDN'T TRUST THE GOVERNMENT
ENOUGH TO FILL OUT THIS FORM.
AND THIS WAS BEFORE THE CLIMATE
OF OUR CURRENT ADMINISTRATION.
THERE ARE AN ESTIMATED AT
SIXTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE CONSIDERED
HARD TO CAL LIKE MY MOTHER.
OUR WORK HAS SHOWN THAT FOR
CBO'S ACROSS THE STATE TO
EDUCATE ENCOURAGE MILLIONS OF
HARD TO COUNT CALIFORNIANS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CENSUS WE
NEED TO INCREASE OUR INVESTMENT
IN THE WORK OF CBO'S BY SEVENTY
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR A TOTAL OF NINETY THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION.
DOLLARS. NINETY THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS.
THIS FUNDING WOULD SUPPORT
ACTIVITIES INCLUDING DOOR TO
DOOR.
CANVASSING COMMUNITY FORUMS AND
PRESENT PRESENTATIONS PHONE
BANKING.
AND AND OTHER ACTIVITIES SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU SPEAKER.
IT UP THE NAME IS THE CHAIR
MARTHA GROUP MEN MEMBERS MIGHT
THE GUERRERO REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
CURRENTLY -- WE ARE EXPERIENCING --
INDIVIDUALS THAT -- HAVE SOME
IMMIGRATION STATUS ISSUES THAT
ARE WITHDRAWING -- FROM
RECEIVING PUBLIC BENEFITS SO
THEY ARE DROPPING THEIR BENEFITS
OUT OF FEAR OF THE IMMIGRATION
REPRISAL THAT IS NOT YET
CURRENTLY HALFPENNY WE'RE TRYING
TO EDUCATE THEM.
BUT THEY ARE REALLY CONCERNED
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS ONE OF THE
HARDEST TO COUNT COUNTIES AND
LAST YEAR WE REQUESTED TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS BECAUSE OF THE
IMMIGRATION ISSUES IN ADDITION
TO THE ADDITIONAL TEN MILLION
THAT WE HAD ASKED FOR WE ADDED
TWO MORE MILLION.
AND WE RECEIVED ONLY -- TEN
MILLION -- TO LESS THAN TEN
MILLION DOLLARS SO WE ARE SHORT
TWO POINT SIX MILLION WE HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL ASK OF TWO POINT FOUR
MILLION BECAUSE WE HAVE -- LOOK
AT HOW WE CAN REACH THE HARDEST
TO REACH AND THEY ARE ADDING
KIOSKS -- AND WE HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENT BY THE
STATE -- FOR DOING OUT REACH TO
NATIVE AMERICANS THOSE WITH
DISABILITIES AND OTHER ISSUES SO
WE URGE YOU -- TO YOU KNOW
PROVIDE LOS ANGELES COUNTY AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
TO FILL THE LOCAL COUNTY
OUTREACH REQUIREMENTS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
NEXT WEEK.
HELLO MY NAME IS YOU NEED TO
BECAUSE YES AND I'M WITH THE
COUNCIL ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS CALIFORNIA.
THE NATION'S LARGEST MUSLIM
CIVIL RIGHTS GROUP AND I'M ALSO
A MEMBER OF SEE PAN THE CENSUS
POLICY ADVOCACY NETWORK.
AND AS IS BEEN STATED
A VOICE
FOR THE VOICELESS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING SUPPORTING.
ALL OF THE PAID MEDIA THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE -- PARTICULARLY --
SET ASIDE A LOT OF THOSE
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
GO TO ENGLISH LANGUAGE ONLY AM
AGAIN YOU'LL HEAR A PROBABLY A
LOT MORE ABOUT THE DETAILS OF IN
LANGUAGE -- BUT BASICALLY THE IT
THIS INCREMENTAL -- INVESTMENT
WILL BE BENEFICIAL TO ALL OF
CALIFORNIA I THINK EVERY TIME.
HELLO AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME MEMBER NAY OSTER I'M I'M
ALSO WITH UNIVISION AND AS A
TRUSTED MESSENGER -- YOU KNOW
THAT REACHES HISPANICS ACROSS
THE STATE THROUGH ALL OF OUR
PLATFORMS RADIO TV AND DIGITAL
WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSED INCREASE
IN THE BUDGET -- I THINK THE
SOMETHING THAT HAS HAPPENED IS A
STATE NORMALLY TRIES TO REACH AS
MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE FOR THE
LEAST AMOUNT OF MONEY WITH
SOMEONE LIKE ME HIS EASY TO
REACH BECAUSE I'M GOING. TO FILL
OUT SENSE IS THE FIRST TIME I
SEE THE CARD.
IS IS A LOW COST.
SOMEONE WHO ARE ON OUR OUR
AUDIENCE THEY HAVE MAYBE NEVER
FILLED OUT SINCE AS BEFORE THERE
ANY NEED TO SEE THIS MESSAGE
SEVEN TEN TIMES ACROSS ALL
DIFFERENT PLATFORMS FROM PEOPLE
THEY TRUST NEWS CASTERS.
AB RADIO DJS THEY NEED FULL
SUPPORT OF THE COMMUNITY TO MAKE
THAT LEAP TO FILL OUT THIS FORM
SEC THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
[inaudible]
SPEAKER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IN
CENTER CERAM SANTANA
REPRESENTING CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION AND WE
SUPPORT THE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT FOR STATEWIDE
OUTREACH FOR CENSUS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT BECAUSE MY ENGRAM
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
AN INCREASED INVESTMENT FOR
CENSUS OUR EACH INCLUDING TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON COOLEY A GANG BUT
THE SOUTHEAST ASIA RESOURCE
ACTION CENTER -- WE ALSO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE INCREASE --
BUDGET.
HI LIZA CHAIR WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA A PARTNERSHIP OF
ASIAN LAW CAUCUS AND ADVANCING
JUSTICE LA WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF
THE INCREASED BUDGET FOR CBO TO
NOT REACH AS THIS HAS PROFOUND
IMPACTS ON NOT JUST FEDERAL
FUNDING BUT REDISTRICTING
POLITICAL REPRESENTATION AND THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ENFORCEMENT OUR
STATE.
A GOOD AFTERNOON JOHN THIS IS A
MAIN CHAMBLISS OR WORLD OR NO --
THE PRINT MEDIA WE ARE HERE TO
OUR SUPPORT INCREASING OFF THE
MEDIA -- SPENDING THE REASON FOR
THAT IS BECAUSE I THINK I
CHINESE CULTURAL WISE HAS A
DIFFERENT SYSTEM THEY THEY'VE
BEEN COUNTED WHEN THEY WAS FIRST
BORN IN THE HOUSE OF REGISTRY.
AND THE SINCE THIS IS A TOTALLY
NEW IDEA -- AND ALSO WITH THE A
VERY HOUSE STYLE -- IMMIGRATION.
VITAMINS SO I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO EDUCATE THE CHINESE
COMMUNITY EARLY ENOUGH TO MAKE
SURE THEY IN THE FIELD OF THE
THE APPLICATION ACCORDING TO THE
TWENTY TENTS AS CENSUS.
THE US AND FRANCISCO ONLY HAVE
LIKE.
21% OF THE CHINESE THEN WE KNOW
IT THAT'S ARE EXTREMELY UNDER
CURRENT SO WE HOPE YOU KNOW.
THAT STATE CAN INCREASE THE
MEDIA A SPENDING AND START TO
EDUCATION PROCESS EARLY THANK
YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
FRANCIS SP THROUGH A PHILIPPINE
YOU SAID PHILIPPINES TODAY. FOR
THE PAST FIFTY YEARS I'VE BEEN
PROVIDING COMMUNITY NEWS THOUGH
THE FILIPINO AMERICAN.
AND I WOULD URGE AND SUPPORT --
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING BECAUSE I
BELIEVE YOU KNOW IT'S A MATTER
OF EDUCATING OUR COMMUNITY OUR
READERS ARE CONSTITUENT.
AND I BELIEVE EVERYBODY SHOULD
BE COUNTED AND FOR EVERY
[inaudible]
ON MISS COUNT THAT IT'S YOU KNOW
DOLLAR DEBT.
SHOULD BE ALLOCATED TO
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO TO THE
FUTURE OF OUR CHILDREN AND GREAT
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN THANK YOU
[inaudible]
NEXT WEEK -- AUDREY RETIRED
CHECK -- FROM CRUISE STRATEGIES
ON BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY
WE'RE APPRECIATIVE AND
SUPPORTIVE OF THE ADDITIONAL
FIFTY FOUR MILLION FOR CENSUS
PLANNING AN OUT REACH.
AND ALSO TO NOTE THAT WE'RE
REQUESTING A THREE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLAR DIRECT ALLOCATION --
FOR PLANNING AND OUTREACH FOR
HARD TO COUNT POPULATIONS THANK
YOU.
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF
SKEWS ME OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY -- WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT
OF THEIR GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
REQUEST AND WE ALSO ARE MAKING
AN ADDITIONAL REQUEST.
ON BEHALF OF THE REGION THREE
COUNTIES -- SEVEN BAY AREA
COUNTIES.
INCLUDING SANTA CLARA TO BE
ALLOCATED ON A PER CAPITA BASIS
AND ASKS FOR FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO ASSIST IN OUR LOCAL
OUTREACH EFFORTS.
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MONICA
MILLER REPRESENT IN THE COUNTY
OF ALAMEDA MY VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
ONE OF THE HARDEST TO COUNT
COUNTIES.
ON IN THE NATION SO WE REALLY
THINK EVERY DOLLAR MAKES A BIG
DIFFERENCE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NO I BOTTOM ALL REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION SERVING
FARMWORKERS AN ISOLATED RURAL
AREAS WE STAND IN SUPPORT FOR
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING THAT'S
BEEN.
ASKED BY AC PAN AND ARE ADVOCACY
GROUPS HERE TODAY AND WE THINK
IT'S A GOOD BEGINNING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR HAS
DONE.
NORDIC MOVE US FORWARD BUT WE
STILL NEED TO DO MORE WORK FOR I
COMMUNITIES IN THIS DIFFICULT
TIME THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ALMA
ROBINSON I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA LAWYERS
FOR THE ARTS.
I WANT TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF OUR
DIVERSE CONSTITUENTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND URGE YOU TO
PROVIDE THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THAT'S NEEDED PARTICULARLY IN
LIGHT OF THE CHALLENGE.
THAT THE FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION
IS POSING.
BY TRYING TO IMPOSE A
REQUIREMENT A QUESTION ABOUT
CITIZENSHIP WHICH WILL
INTIMIDATE PEOPLE FROM
COMPLETING CENSUS QUESTIONNAIRE
SO THANK YOU AND TO THE
GOVERNOR'S WELL. FOR SUPPORTING
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYBODY IN
CALIFORNIA GETS COUNTED THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT CLOSES
PUBLIC COMMENT AND OBVIOUSLY
THIS ITEM WILL BE HELD OPEN --
OF ENDING FURTHER BUDGET
DISCUSSIONS LET'S MOVE TO ITEM
SEVENTEEN AROUND LANGUAGE ACCESS
ISSUES HAVING TO DO WITH THE
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS.
TURNED BACK.
TO THE COMPLETE CONSENSUS.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO THIS GUITAR G.
HERE.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMPLETE COUNT SINCE THIS OFFICE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ON A CRITICAL COMPONENT.
OF OUR OUTREACH EFFORTS RELATED
TO LANGUAGE AND COMMUNICATIONS
ACCESS.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME IN THE
HISTORY IN CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY
THE DOLLARS ARE EARMARKED FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT OF A LANGUAGE
AND COMMUNICATION ACCESS
STRATEGY AND ASSOCIATED
STANDARDS.
AS OF TODAY NO OTHER STATE HAS
CREATED A STREAMLINED PROCESS TO
ADDRESS LANGUAGE AND
COMMUNICATION ACCESS.
HOWEVER WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THE LANGUAGE OF COMMUNICATION
THAT LANGUAGE AND COMMUNICATION
ACCESS IS AT THE VERY HEART AND
THE FRONT AND CENTER OF OUR
PRIORITIES IN OUR OUTREACH
CAMPAIGN.
IT IS EMBEDDED VIRTUALLY IN
EVERY FACET OF OUR OUTREACH
EFFORTS AND THIS INCLUDES OUT
REACH BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT
YOU HEARD FROM REGIONAL AND
STATEWIDE COMMITTEE BASS
ORGANIZATIONS THAT YOU ALSO
HEARD FROM.
AND THE PUBLIC RELATIONS MEDIA
CAMPAIGN.
THE CENSUS OFFICE IS CURRENTLY
DRAFTING A LANGUAGE AND
COMMUNICATIONS ACCESS STANDARD
DOCUMENT.
THE PURPOSE OF THESE STANDARDS
IS TO OUTLINE THE KEY LANGUAGE
INDUSTRY CONCEPTS COMPLIANCE
WITH PERTINENT LAWS AN OVER
ARCHING FRAMEWORK TO ENSURE
MESSAGING IS CULTURALLY RELEVANT.
AND TO GUARANTEE MEANINGFUL
COMMUNICATION.
UNFORTUNATELY THE U. S. CENSUS
BUREAU DID NOT PROVIDE
GUIDELINES FOR QUALITY ASSURANCE
IN LANGUAGE SERVICES TO LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENT INDIVIDUALS
AND AS YOU KNOW OUR EFFORTS ARE
OUT REACH EFFORTS ARE IN SUPPORT.
OF THE ACTUAL ENUMERATION
OPERATIONS WHICH IS RUN BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
OUR LOW COST AS WHICH WE CALL
OUR LANGUAGE AND COMMUNICATION
ACCESS STANDARDS OUTLINED IN
DEFINES THE QUALITY OF LANGUAGE
ACCESS AND CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE SERVICES.
THESE TERMS ARE SELDOM A DEFINED
WITHOUT CLEARS AND WITHOUT CLEAR
STANDARDS INSUFFICIENT LANGUAGE
SERVICES COULD MEAN HOUSEHOLDS
AND ENTIRE COMMUNITIES WILL BE
OVERLOOKED AND UNDER COUNTED.
IS THE GOAL OF THE CENSUS OFFICE
TO ESTABLISH A PROCESS OF
TRANSPARENCY IN AND CAL AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IN MITIGATING ALL
BARRIERS.
THIS IS ACCOMPLISHED BY THE
ESTABLISH MECHANISM OF OUR
OFFICE NEEDING TO REVIEW AND
APPROVE PLANS PRIOR TO
DISBURSEMENT OF ANY OF OUR STATE
FUNDS FOR IMPLEMENTATION TO OUR
PARTNERS.
OUR OFFICE WILL FOCUS MORE ON
LANGUAGE IS NOT ADDRESSED BY THE
US CENSUS BUREAU AS FAR AS
MATERIALS BUT OUT REACHED SHOULD
STILL BE DONE IN THE LANGUAGES
SPOKEN IN CALIFORNIA.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO RECEIVING
COMMENTS AND FEEDBACK FROM OUR
STAKEHOLDERS AS WE CONTINUE TO
ESTABLISH OUR LANGUAGE AND
COMMUNICATION ACCESS STANDARDS
FOR THE REMAINDER OF THIS MONTH.
WE'RE PLANNING TO HAVE THE NEXT
ITERATION OF THE LOW COST AT THE
END OF APRIL.
HOWEVER BASED ON THE EXTENT OF
FEEDBACK WE RECEIVED OR HORK HOW
COMPLEX IT IS WE WANT TO TAKE
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION FOR A
TIME LINE.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THEY SAY IT
TAKES ABOUT A VILLAGE BUT TO
REALLY GET A COMPLETE COUNT FOR
CALIFORNIA IT TAKES ALL VILLAGES
IN ALL COMMUNITIES.
SO WITH THAT YOUR AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION
AND I KNOW YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE.
HOW MUCH LANGUAGE AXIS -- COULD
LIKELY BE THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
BARRIER TO PARTICIPATION.
IN THE CENSUS -- AND I KNOW
THERE A LOT OF CONCERNS HAVE
BEEN RAISED CERTAINLY ABOUT --
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S
APPROACH FOR LACK OF APPROACH TO
THIS AND HOW IMPORTANT IS FOR
CALIFORNIA TO TO STEP UP SO -- I
FOR ONE ALONG WITH I THINK MANY
OF OUR COLLEAGUES WILL BE
WATCHING EAGERLY HOW -- THE
ADMINISTRATION CHOOSES TO MOVE
FORWARD ON THIS.
I'M GOING TO PUT ON MY HAT AS
THE CHAIR OF THE API LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS AND REITERATE
SPECIFICALLY WITH REGARDS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES -- AS AS YOU KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF DATA THAT SHOWS --
THAT THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ARE LEAST LIKELY
TO BE FAMILIAR WITH THE CENSUS.
MOST LIKELY TO SAY THAT THEIR
ANSWERS TO THE SENSES WILL BE
USED AGAINST THEM.
MOST SKEPTICAL OF THE QUESTION
OF WHETHER OR NOT THEY BELIEVE
THAT CENSUS INFORMATION -- WILL
BENEFIT OUR COMMUNITIES AND
GENERALLY LEAST LIKELY TO
PARTICIPATING GIVEN THE LANGUAGE
DIVERSITY WITH THEIR I. P. I
COMMUNITIES -- I WOULD JUST SAY
I'M PARTICULARLY INTERESTED ON
BEHALF OF MANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES
AND KNOWING WHAT THAT IS GOING
TO LOOK LIKE.
I KNOW THAT THERE BEEN A NUMBER
OF PROPOSALS OPTICALLY COMING
FROM CHINESE FOR AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION THAT HAVE LAID OUT A
NUMBER OF SUGGESTIONS AND AND
AND HOW TO MOVE FORWARD AROUND.
HAVING THE STATE CREATE AN
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN THAT GOES
FARTHER THAN THE GUIDELINES THAT
HAVE BEEN PROVIDED SO FAR.
TRANSLATING ADDITIONAL LANGUAGES
OUTSIDE OF THE FEDERALLY
MANDATED ONES SPECIFYING WHAT
FUNDING COULD GO TO WHICH GROUPS
SPECIFYING.
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES AND PRIORITY
LANGUAGES AND WORKING WITH CBO
IS TO FULFILL THOSE PRIORITIES --
AND AND THINKING ABOUT LANGUAGE
ACCESS AS SOMETHING WE HAVE TO
DO NOT SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
OPTIONAL AND AGAIN I KNOW YOU
UNDERSTAND THIS AND KNOW THIS
BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY THIS
PUBLICLY -- I THINK MANY OF US
ARE WE'RE VERY VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT MAY HAPPEN AND WE
ONLY HAVE ONE SHOT TO GET IT
RIGHT SO -- I WOULD JUST SAY ON
BEHALF OF MANY BEST PARTICULAR
BEHALF OF OUR ETHNIC CAUCUSES WE
WOULD LOVE -- IN THE NEXT COUPLE
WEEKS OF A BRIEFING ON WHERE
THIS IS GOING TO BE SO THAT BY
THE TIME THIS COMES BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A PLAN THAT WE ALL FEEL
GOOD ABOUT AND ARE READY TO TO
SUPPORT -- SO WITH THAT I WANT
TO ASK IF -- DEPARTMENT FINANCE
IF YOU ANYTHING YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SAY REALLY BRIEFLY AND THE
ADMINISTRATION UNDERSTANDS THE
IMPORTANCE OF ADDRESSING
LANGUAGE ACCESS ISSUES AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF ON THIS IS.
FOR THE REST OF SPRING CAN I
SHOULD SAY OUR CAUCUS SAT DOWN
WITH -- THE NEW GOVERNOR AND AND
WE KNOW HE GETS IT AND WE'RE
REALLY LOOKING FOR WORKING IN
PARTNERSHIP TO TO MOVE THE SPORT
IN A GOOD WAY -- ELIA WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS RIGHT ME ASK
IF ANY COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON THIS [inaudible]
IF NOT [inaudible]
OKAY.
LET'S OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
CENTER CERAM SANTANA.
REPRESENTING CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
OUR ORGANIZATION HAS A GREAT
DEAL OF EXPERIENCE WORKING ON
CENSUS SINCE OUR FOUNDING IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE I'VE WORKED
ON EVERY DECENNIAL CENSUS FOR
THE PAST FIVE DECADES.
AND SO.
FIRST WE'D LIKE TO THANK THIS
COMMITTEE AND STAFF FOR
PRIORITIZING LANGUAGE ACCESS IN
THE STATE CENSUS OUTREACH
EFFORTS.
LAST YEAR THIS COMMITTEE.
MADE A SPECIFIC REQUEST THAT A
LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN BE PRODUCED
BY THE STATE CENSUS OFFICE.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THE PLAN AND THAT'S THE
CURRENT DRAFT PLAN IS MISSING A
LOT OF DETAILS. FOR THE CENSUS
POINT FOR CALIFORNIA CENSUS
EFFORTS TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
OUR STATE LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN
MUST BE ROBUST WITH DETAILS IT
MUST IDENTIFY THE LANGUAGE GAPS
AND ARTICULATELY STATE HOW THOSE
GAPS WILL BE FILLED.
THE PLAN MUST ADDRESS THE UNIQUE.
LINGUISTIC COMMUNITIES OF
CALIFORNIA BOTH LARGE SMALL AND
SMALLER THE MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
PLAN MUST BE OPERATIONAL WITH
MEASURABLE -- OF DELIVERABLES SO
IN IN CLOSING WE WILL.
US ALONG WITH OTHER CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION AND IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION HAVE
SUBMITTED WRITTEN.
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE STATE
CENSUS OFFICE AND WE HOPE TO SEE
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS REFLECTED
IN THE NEXT ITERATION OF THE
PLAN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SPEAKER.
MY ANGER I'M ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
ONLINE MY COMMENTS WITH CHINESE
FOR AFFIRMATIVE ACTION AND
STRESSED THE NEED FOR A CLEAR
PLAN.
THAT IS OPERATIONAL AND ROBUST
HAS ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES
REALLY LOOKS ON HOW IT CAN FILL
IN THE STATE AND LOCAL GAPS THAT
HAVE BEEN CREATED BY THE FEDERAL
PLAN.
AND THAT REALLY TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT HOW IT'S GONNA REACH
SMALL LANGUAGES AND NON RIGHT
LANGUAGES THANK YOU.
HELLO AGAIN -- GO HERE WITH THE
SOUTHEAST ASIA RESOURCE ACTION
CENTER ALSO KNOWN AS C. RACK.
C. RACK IS THE ONLY NATIONAL AND
STATE WHY SOUTHEAST ASIAN CIVIL
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS
WITH -- THOSE WHO ARE REFUGEE
COMMUNITIES FROM LAOS CAMBODIA
AND VIETNAM I WE WORK WITH
PARTNERS THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
ADDRESS PRESSING ISSUES LIKE
HEALTH EDUCATIONSENSES.
AND ALSO IMMIGRATION TODAY
THERE'S ABOUT ONE MILLION
SOUTHEAST ASIAN THAT RESIDES IN
CALIFORNIA DUE TO OUR
COMMUNITIES LOW EDUCATION
ATTAINMENT HIGH POVERTY RATES.
AND LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
PROFICIENCY WE ARE ONE OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S HARD TO COUNT
COMMUNITIES.
ALMOST 70% OF OUR COMMUNITIES
ARE LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT --
AND SO REACHING OUR SMALLER
COMMUNITIES FOR CENSUS TWENTY
TWENTY MEANS HAVING A THOUGHTFUL
LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN.
IN PLACE TO OUT REACHING
CRITICAL LINKAGES -- INCLUDING
CAMBODIAN LONG NOW AND YOU ME
AND BECAUSE SOUTHEAST ASIAN
COMMUNITIES ARE SMALLER OUR
NEEDS ARE OFTEN INVISIBLE TO
POLICY MAKERS.
SINCE THE DATA IS A PRIORITY FOR
OUR COMMUNITIES BECAUSE IT'S
REALLY THE ONLY NATIONAL DATA --
THAT THIS AGGREGATES ARE
SOUTHEAST ASIAN OR SOME OF THE
SOUTHEAST ASIAN AMERICAN DATA --
INCLUDING EDUCATION COMPLETION
POVERTY RATES AND HEALTH
INSURANCE -- SO TO ENSURE A FULL
FAIR AND ACCURATE CENSUS COUNT
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES WE REALLY
WANT -- TO WE HOPE THAT THIS
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
ALLOWING US TO WORK WITH YOU TO
DEVELOP AN INCLUSIVE LANGUAGE
ACCESS PLAN.
ON THAT REALLY ADDRESSES THE
NEEDS FOR SMALLER LANGUAGE
GROUPS AND ALSO LANGUAGE GROUPS
THAT ARE NON WRITTEN.
AS WELL AS LANGUAGE GROUPS LIKE
THE MALL COMMUNITY WHERE THERE
IS A WRITING SYSTEM BUT OFTEN
TIMES -- OUR ELDERS ARE NOT
LITERATE IN A WRITING SYSTEM
BECAUSE IT IS SO NEW -- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME [inaudible]
ALL.
YOU NEED A DISEASE OF THE
COUNCIL ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS CALIFORNIA AND A
MEMBER OF THE SENSES POLICY
ADVOCACY NETWORK WE WANT TO ECHO
THE STATEMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
SAID -- BEFORE US BY PHIL
ADVOCATES AND ALLIES -- AND JUST
WANT TO REITERATE REALLY THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE STATE --
REALLY TAKING INITIATIVE AND AND
LEADING IN THE COUNTRY IN
REGARDS LANGUAGE ACCESS
CURRENTLY THERE WILL ONLY BE
SPANISH AND ENGLISH AND PRINTED
VERSION FOR THE CENSUS FORM.
AND ONLINE THEY'RE ONLY DOING
ABOUT TWELVE LANGUAGES AM AND
NONE OF THOSE LANGUAGES ARE
ACTUALLY PACIFIC ISLANDER.
AND THAT'S A HUGE PROBLEM AS WAS
MENTIONED -- DURING THE UP A
LITTLE EARLIER IN SOME OF THE
COMMENTS IT'S JUST REALLY
IMPORTANT IN ADDITION BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA HAS ONE OF THE
LARGEST REFUGEE COMMUNITIES.
AND THE IMPORTANCE ON ENSURING
THAT SPOKEN LANGUAGES.
ARE CONSIDERED AS WELL FOR THOSE
SMALL -- POPULATIONS AS WELL AS
INDIGENOUS LANGUAGES SO WE
SUPPORT THIS -- BEING HELD OPEN
AND WOULD LOVE TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH YOU ARE THANK YOU.
HELLO ESPERANZA AGAIN GOOD
AFTERNOON I WOULD CHIRLA I JUST
WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT --
FELLOW ADVOCATES AND COLLEAGUES
HAVE ALSO MADE -- WE ENCOURAGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO INCLUDE MORE
DETAILS FRANKLIN IMPLEMENTATION
AND MORE MEASURABLE OUTCOMES WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE A LANGUAGE
ACCESS PLAN THAT CAN FILL THAT
GAP AT THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL.
OF FOR EXAMPLE HOW TO ADDRESS
THE NEEDS OF IMMIGRANTS WHO DO
NOT SPEAK EITHER ENGLISH OR
SPANISH.
I AND WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT THE
LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN CONSIDERS
NON WRITTEN LANGUAGES AS WELL --
WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SEE
CREATION THE CREATION OF
UNIFORMITY RULES THAT ARE THAT
ARE TRULY CULTURALLY COMPETENT
THANK YOU.
HI FAMILIES -- WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA WE ARE ONE OF THE CO
SIGNERS ON THE LETTER OF
RECOMMENDATIONS.
FOR THE CURRENT CENSUS LANGUAGE
ACCESS PLAN -- I WOULD
UNDERSCORE THAT THE BUREAU
CONTINUES TO EXCLUDE DIGITAL
SURVEYS IN LONG PUNJAB BE MY TIE
MARSHALLESE IN TONGAN AMONG MANY
IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA LANGUAGES --
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF LEAVING THIS
ITEM OPEN AND CONTINUING
CONVERSATION ON MANDATING AND
NOT JUST -- SUGGESTING LANGUAGE
ACCESS AS A MATTER AS A PRIORITY
FOR OUR SENSES -- AND THAT THE
FAILURE TO CONFRONT AND ADDRESS
THE ON THE GROUND CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH LANGUAGE WILL --
JEOPARDIZE THE EFFICACY OF ALL
OF OUR STATE DOLLARS PUT INTO
THE CENSUS THANK YOU.
NO I BOTTOM ALL CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION
STAND IN SUPPORT OF A STRONG.
LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN AND APPLAUD
THE EFFORT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS BECAUSE THIS IS A VERY
CRUCIAL FOR A COMMUNITIES
WORKING WITH FARMWORKERS 90% ARE
FROM MEXICO ONE IN THREE OF
THOSE FARMWORKERS ARE FROM A
COMMUNITY OTHER.
THAN -- SPANISH SPEAKING AND
THESE ARE INDIGENOUS COMMUNITIES
ARE SPEAK EITHER MYSTICAL TRICKY
ARTS OPTICAL SO IT'S GOING TO BE
A A CHALLENGE TO MAKE SURE WE
GET TO THOSE COMMUNITIES.
AND SO WE NEED TO REDUCE THOSE
BARRIERS AND WORKING WITH THEM
AND YOU TRUSTED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE THESE
MESSENGERS.
THEY NEED TO GO BEYOND JUST
PURELY.
TRANSLATING INFORMATION THEY'RE
GONNA NEED TO WORK WITH SOMEONE
ON ONE HAND RELIANCE ON THE
INTERNET IS NOT GOING TO DO IT
WE NEED TO WORK WITH OUR
COMMUNITIES SO THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THIS.
LANGUAGE ACCESS PLANS CAN BE
INSTRUMENTAL IN MOVING FORWARD
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
I THANK ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT HAVE COME OUT FOR
THIS ITEM YOU ARE CERTAINLY
REFLECTING AT LEAST SOME OF THE
DIVERSITY OF WHAT WE HAVE IN OUR
STATE WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
SENSES COUNT AND I THINK WE ALL
LOOK FORWARD TO THE NEXT STEPS --
ON THIS PLAN AND IN STAY TUNED.
AND WITH THAT I'M GONNA TURN THE
CHAIRMAN OF THIS MEETING BACK TO
MR AS THIS AREA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU FOR YOUR
WONDERFUL WORK UP WHILE YOU'RE
HERE.
WHY DON'T WE I KNOW EVERYONE IS
RUNNING OFFER DIFFERENT
PRESENTATIONS BUT WHY DON'T WE
GO AHEAD AND VOTE ON SOME OF THE
ITEMS THAT -- WE'VE LEFT OPEN.
I THINK WHERE WE LEFT OFF WAS
[inaudible]
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible] ELEVEN
REALLY NO [inaudible]
THAT [inaudible]
IS.
THERE WERE THERE WAS NO MOTION
BECAUSE THERE WAS ONLY TWO OF US.
AT THAT TIME SO -- IS THERE A
MOTION TO ADOPT TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE -- FOR THE THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE ON THE
FISCAL PROJECT.
LET'S NOT SUPPORTING THE PROJECT.
THE BILL LANGUAGE RIGHT YES
RIGHT LET'S MAKE THAT VERY CLEAR.
I I THINK WE HOLD OUR NOSE IN
VOTING ON ANYTHING HAVING TO DO
WITH THIS PROJECT BUT FOR
PURPOSES OF MOVING THIS
PARTICULAR TRAILER BILL FORD I'M
I'M.
OKAY WITH SUPPORTING THE MOTION.
THERE'S A MOTION [inaudible]
THE SECOND [inaudible]
NAZARIAN HI.
CHIU HI LACKEY.
WICKS.
AT FOURTEEN THANK YOU.
AND THEN ITEM. FOURTEEN FOURTEEN
THANK YOU SOME OF A LITTLE BIT
THANK YOU SECOND [inaudible]
NAZARIAN HI.
CHIU I LACKEY [inaudible] SIX
AND HAVE.
A GREAT.
OKAY.
THE TECHNOLOGY IS THE LAST.
ONE SO LET'S GO.
TO LET'S GO BACK TO ITEM.
NUMBER THIRTEEN ON GOING ARTS
INVESTMENT.
SO [inaudible]
HELLO.
I WAS IN [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
HELLO.
FLOOR IS YOURS.
OKAY BUT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HEARING ASSN HAVING US HERE
TODAY WHAT IS BEING PROPOSED AND
AND WAS CENTER BE CITY BUT IT'S
THE PROPOSED BY.
THE GOVERNOR IS A AN INCREASE OF
TEN MILLION DOLLARS TO OUR
BUDGET.
AND WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THAT VERY
MUCH SO -- EVEN THAT WOULD BE
HELP US WITH OUR ON GOING.
ARTS PORTFOLIO OF FUNDING --
THAT INCLUDES ARTS EDUCATION AND
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS AND ALSO -- I
START GENERAL RATING SUPPORT TO
ARTS ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL AS A
FULL PORTFOLIO PROGRAMS THAT ARE
REALLY FOCUSED ON ARTS AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE.
SO WE'RE HERE TO JUST ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE OF
US -- THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
ANY COMMENTS.
FROM FINANCER ELIA THE CONTENTS.
ARE A BUT THIS ITEM IS GOING TO
BE HELD OPEN SO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOU THANK
YOU.
AS A WEAK PRESENTATION.
HELLO IS THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT.
PLEASE SORRY ABOUT THAT.
I WAS EXPECTING A LITTLE BIT
MORE FROM THE PRESENTATION.
BUT SINCE IT WAS.
SO MEET CERTAIN WILL LEAVE IT AT
THAT.
I DO WANT TO PASS ON A LITTLE
PACKET IF THAT'S APPROPRIATE.
MY NAME IS ALMA ROBINSON I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
LAWYERS FOR THE ARTS I'M SO
SORRY THAT MY ASSEMBLYMAN JUST
LEFT THE ROOM BECAUSE IT'S IT'S
A TOUGH DAY IT'S A HARD BAY
MEANWHILE IS.
HEARINGS AND PRESENTATIONS
TAKING PLACE THAT'S WHY YOU'RE
CONSTANTLY SEEING -- CHANGES.
OF OF OF OF FOLKS LEAVING AND
COMING BACK AGAIN.
RIGHT SO WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR INTEREST IN THE ARTS
YOU HAVE BEEN STEADFAST THROUGH
THESE YEARS AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT -- WE
WERE HERE TODAY AT A MEETING OF
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL AND
I PASSED OUT.
A REPORT ON A DEMONSTRATION
PROJECT THAT WE DID IN COUNTY
JAILS AND WITH THE SUPPORT OF
THE ARTS COUNCIL AS WELL AS THE
NATIONAL ENDOWMENT FOR THE ARTS.
AND OTHER PRIVATE FUNDING WE
WERE ABLE TO PLACE ARTISTS IN
FIFTEEN COUNTIES IN COUNTY JAILS.
AND AS YOU MAY KNOW THERE'S A
VERY GENEROUS OF SUPPORT FROM
THE AT CDC ARE TO THE ARTS
COUNCIL FOR PROGRAMS IN STATE
PRISONS BUT THERE'S A GAP.
THERE ARE ABOUT SEVENTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS BEING HELD LONGER
IN COUNTY DETENTION AND SO WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO SHOW THE BENEFITS
OF ARTS PROGRAMS IN THIS SETTING.
AND WE'RE HOPING THAT THE ARTS
COUNCIL WILL FIND A WAY TO
SUSTAIN THESE PROGRAMS TO
SOMETHING LIKE A MILLION TO
MILLION HALF DOLLARS A YEAR --
OF SUSTAINABLE FUNDING THAT'S
PERHAPS PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
INCREASE SO WE JUST WANTED TO
PUT THAT IDEA OUT THERE YOU'LL
HEAR FROM A COUPLE OF OTHER
PEOPLE WHO HAVE.
EXPERIENCED THIS PROGRAM AND IN
VARIOUS WAYS THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THE ARTS.
OUR ORGANIZATION BENEFITS FROM
ARTS PROGRAMS -- FROM OF THIS
THIS STATE.
STATEWIDE AND REGIONAL SUPPORT
THAT WE GET IS AN ARTS SERVICE
ORGANIZATION ALSO FROM
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
CONSULTING.
WHICH HAS BEEN VERY VALUABLE FOR
ORGANIZATION AND THE ARTS
COUNCIL IS HELPING US TO
PRODUCES A NATIONAL CONFERENCE.
AT SANTA CLARA UNIVERSITY AT THE
END OF JUNE ON ARTS AND
CORRECTIONS WHICH WILL DRAW
PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
AND EVEN INTERNATIONALLY.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
PORT.
HI ERICA HI AM JULIE BAKER I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR THE ARTS IN
CALIFORNIA ARTS ADVOCATES AND WE
HAVE BOARD MEMBERS FROM ACROSS
THE STATE SAN FRANCISCO OAKLAND
LOS ANGELES NEVADA CITY
CALIFORNIA RURAL TO THE NORTH
AND SOUTH -- WE WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR LONG
STANDING SUPPORT OF THE ARTS AND
MOVING THAT FORWARD AND WE WANT
TO THANK A GOVERNOR NEWSOME FOR
HIS PRO ACTIVE SUPPORT OF THE
ARTS BY.
INCLUDING THAT TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN PERMANENT FUNDING FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL.
FROM WHY IS INCREASED FUNDING
NECESSARY WELL LET'S LOOK AT
SOME NUMBERS SO THERE ARE ELEVEN
THOUSAND ARTS AND CULTURE --
NONPROFIT IN CALIFORNIA IN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCILS
GRANTS THEY'RE ABLE TO SERVE
ONLY 7% OF THOSE ELEVEN THOUSAND
NON PROFITS.
IN THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN SCHEDULE -- WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL
ANTICIPATES IS ABOUT THIRTY
THREE MILLION IN GRANTS REQUEST
AND WHICH THEY CAN ONLY RESULT
IN FUNDING ABOUT 57% -- IN TERMS
OF OVERALL WHERE WE STAND --
ACROSS THE NATION WE KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA LIKES TO BE IN THE
LEAD AND WE BELIEVE CALIFORNIA
IS THE STATE OF THE ARTS BUT LET
ME GIVE YOU A LITTLE PROGRESS
REPORT EVEN WITH THE TEN MILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE.
WE'RE STILL UNDER ONE DOLLAR PER
CAPITA PER PERSON -- WHERE THE
NATIONAL MEDIAN IS A DOLLAR TEN
SO WE'RE NOT QUITE THERE YET BUT
WE SUPER APPRECIATE THE TEN
MILLION?
WE ALSO KNOW THE CALIFORNIA IS A
LEADER IN THE CREATIVE ECONOMY
WITH THE CREATIVE INDUSTRIES
REPRESENTING AND THIS IS
INCREDIBLE NUMBER SEVEN POINT 1%
OF THE STATE'S ECONOMY AHEAD OF
AGRICULTURE AND TRANSPORTATION.
AND THIS IS FROM A RECENT U. S.
BUREAU OF ECONOMIC ANALYST'S
REPORT IN ADDITION A TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ANALYSIS OF
DUN AND BRADSTREET BROAD STREET
DATE ACCOUNTS FIVE POINT 1% OF
STATE BUSINESSES AND TWO POINT
9% OF ALL EMPLOYEES.
ARE INVOLVED IN THE CREATION AND
DISTRIBUTION OF THE ARTS SO WE
LIKE TO SAY WE ARE NO LONGER THE
ICING ON THE CAKE WE ARE THE
CAKE GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND LET'S KEEP IT BRIEF PLEASE
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JERRY SCHWAB
PREMIERE -- ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR
OF CALIFORNIA LAWYERS FOR THE
ARTS.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR NUISANCE BUDGET ALSO
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL --
AND ALSO OF INCREASED FUNDING
FOR COUNTY JAIL OUR PROGRAMS.
DON'T UNDERESTIMATE THE VALUE OF
ARTS AND CREATIVE I THINK THEY
MAY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO HELP SOLVE.
SOME OF THE PROBLEMS WE SAW HERE
TODAY.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JASON HEATH AND I
AM THE PROGRAM CORNERED
COORDINATOR AND LEAD TEACHING
OURS FOR JOE **** DOORS WHERE
NONPROFIT BASED IN.
LOS ANGELES WE FIND SOME MUSIC
PROGRAMS AND SONGWRITING
WORKSHOPS AROUND THE COUNTRY ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY PRESENCE WE
ALSO ARE.
ARE RECEIVING FUNDING TO THE CDC
ARE THROUGH WILLIAM JAMES
ASSOCIATION TO BE AND AND
PRESENTS AND WE WORK IN THE
COUNTY JAILS AS WELL SO -- WHAT
WE DO THAT ON A VOLUNTARY BASIS
AND ACTUAL OUR FLAGS SHIP
PROGRAM THAT WE STARTED THERE BY
THE PROGRAM WHAT WE DEVELOPED
OUR CURRICULUM IS BASED OUT OF --
TWIN TOWERS IN DOWNTOWN LOS AND
JUST AND WE ARE STILL ON A
VOLUNTEER BASIS THERE WERE
WITHOUT FUNDING SO WE JUST WANT
TO ECHO WHAT ON THE WAS SAYING
ABOUT -- CHRIS FUNDING FOR THE
LOCAL.
COUNTY JAILS THANKS VERY MUCH
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M DAMIEN BROWN
ARTIST IN RESIDENCE FOR MARINE
SHAKESPEARE COMPANY I AM A
PRODUCT OF THE INVESTMENT IN
ARTS IN CORRECTIONS.
I WAS PART OF MARIN SIX PER
COMPANIES PROGRAM.
AND I ENDED THAT PROGRAM WITH
MEN THAT I HAD KNOWN FOR MORE
THAN TWENTY YEARS WERE VERY
HARDENED.
GANG MEMBERS AND CRIMINALS NONE
OF US WANT ANYTHING TO DO WITH
ONE ANOTHER WHEN WE INTO THAT
ROOM.
BUT THROUGH THE PROCESS OF GOING
THROUGH PLAYS IN PRODUCTIONS IN
WORKING OUT THESE THINGS YOU HAD
MEN WHOSE.
SOCIAL CULTURE HAD TOLD THEM YOU
DO NOT GO TO DOCTORS
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND PSYCHIATRISTS
TO WORK OUT TO ISSUE.
BUT WE WERE ABLE TO WORK OUT
THOSE THINGS THROUGH CHARACTERS.
MAKE BETH WAS ACTUALLY TO PLAY
AND WE KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF BAD
THINGS HAPPENING THERE'S A SOME
OF THOSE THINGS REALLY AFFECTED
UP 290% OF THE PEOPLE IN THAT
ROOM.
SO THEY WERE ABLE TO REALLY WORK
ON THEIR INTERNAL ISSUES.
THROUGH THATPROGRAM.
AFTER WE DID THAT AND I CAME
HOME FORTUNATELY I WAS ABLE TO
LAND A JOB AS AN ARTIST.
I AM NOW AND MOTOR WHAT WINNING
ARTISTS AND OF HAS BROUGHT THE
WAY FROM BLACK PANTHER.
SO I REALLY.
AND THE I NEVER WOULD HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
HAD NO ONE OFFERED THAT.
SO MY PERSONAL MOTTO COMING HOME
WAS TO DEPRIVE PRISONS OF THE
LIFE BLOOD DEFEATS THEM.
I MERELY WANT TO WORKING AS A
HIGH RISK CASE MANAGERS SAN
FRANCISCO SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
WITH -- COMMUNITY WORKS WEST.
AND IN DOING THAT WE HAD TO FIND
WAYS TO CREATE PLANS OF ACTION
FOR TRANSITIONAL AGE YOU.
WHO WERE VERY HIGH RISK GUN
CHARGES?
SHOOTINGS ALL OF THOSE THINGS SO
I FOUND IT VERY EASY TO HELP
THEM.
WHEN THEY WERE [inaudible]
ARTISTICALLY INCLINED.
I TOOK SOME OF THEIR WORK AND I
HAD IT PUT IN SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC LIBRARY.
SO THAT THEY COULD.
BE SEEN IN A DIFFERENT LIGHT
OTHER THAN THE ONE THAT THEY
HAVE COME TO EMBRACE.
BEING THAT I WAS IN THEATER I
WAS ABLE TO TAKE CERTAIN MUSIC
PIECES CERTAIN ART PIECES AND
UTILIZE THEM BETWEEN BREAKS.
IN THOSE THINGS AND HAVE THESE
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN COME AND SEE
THOSE PRODUCTIONS AND SEE THERE
ART.
THE PEOPLE HAD PAID TO COME AND
WITNESS. TO ME I SAW THAT
CHANGED THE LANDSCAPE OF HOW NOT
ONLY HOW THEY SAW THIS SOCIETY
TO COMMUNITY BUT HOW THE
COMMUNITY STARTED TO SEE THEM.
AND THAT INCREASES ONE'S SELF
ESTEEM IN A WAY TO WERE BY THEIR
NOT LOOKING ANYMORE TO PREY UPON
SOCIETY.
BABY LONG TO THAT SOCIETY.
AS MUCH AS IT BELONGS TO THEM.
AND THAT CHILLS MARGINALIZATION.
SO I WOULD APPRECIATE.
ANY ASSISTANCE IN KEEPING THAT
PROGRAM GOING AND ALSO I'M SO
SORRY.
OPENED IN TWO MINUTES TO GET RE
SECONDS.
IS INTERNATIONAL INTEREST IN
THIS I'VE BEEN INVITED TO LONDON
CALCUTTA AND ANTIGUA. TO DISCUSS
THOSE PRODUCTS PROGRESS IS A WE
HAD MADE HEARING CALIFORNIA
NEVER THOUGHT I'D BE A
REPRESENTATIVES CDC OR.
BUT IS HAVING AN EFFECT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND YOU'RE ALWAYS
WELCOME TO COME IN AND PROVIDE
THE REAL LIFE EXAMPLE OF HOW WE
CAN MAKE AN IMPACT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING YOU AGAIN.
I COULD JUST ADD ONE THING
BEFORE WE BEFORE WERE EXCUSED IF
YOU DON'T MIND [inaudible]
OKAY -- GO AHEAD OKAY.
I'M VERY SORRY I WASN'T
EXPECTING TO DO A LOT OF
SPEAKING TODAY BECAUSE I JUST
WAS EXPECTED BUT I AM A YOUNG TO
KEEP WARY OF THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL
THIS IS.
CHRIS MARGOLIS OUR LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS DIRECTOR I WANTED TO
JUST ADD ONE PIECE THAT WAS NOT
SPOKEN TO ALREADY THAT THE WITH
THIS INCREASE FUNDING WE ARE AM
DEDICATING TIME AND EFFORT AND
RESOURCES TOWARDS.
A COMPREHENSIVE EVALUATION OF
OUR GRANT PORTFOLIO SO THAT WE
CAN SHOW SOME OUTCOMES IDENTIFY --
OUTCOMES THAT'S USUALLY NOT THE
CASE A LOT OF TIMES WITH GRANT
PROGRAMMING BUT IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO US WE HAVE MADE AN
INVESTMENT IN THAT AS WELL AS A
STRATEGIC PLANNING VISITING
PRESENT A FRAMEWORK PROCESS
WE'RE UNDERGOING THAT FRAMEWORK --
START WE'RE STARTING THAT CITY
TO PRIMARK RIGHT NOW SO THAT WE
CAN REALLY SEE.
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS MAKING A
DIFFERENCE THANK YOU THAT WILL
INCLUDE THE THE LEGISLATURE'S AS
WELL YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A ON MY
SURVEY THANK YOU OKAY?
SORRY WE GOT TO KEEP THIS GOING.
SO LET'S GO BACK AND VOTE ON A
COUPLE OF ITEMS ISSUE NUMBER TEN
TAXPAYER OUT REGION PREPARATION
ASSISTANCE.
IS A VOTE.
BUT I SHE HIGH BACK MADAM MISS
WICKS FANTASTIC [inaudible]
ISSUE.
ELEVEN TRAVEL GOING TO ISSUE
ITEM [inaudible]
ELEVEN SHE FOURTEENTH.
IF YOU ITEM.
FOURTEEN FANTASTIC THANK YOU.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST.
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY ISSUE.
ITEMS EIGHTEEN AND NINETEEN
LET'S START WITH SECURITY
OPERATIONS CENTER.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR A MEMBER OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
SAYING HI TO THE VERY END WITH
US TO START WE CAN PRESENT OUR
BUDGET PROPOSAL MY NAME IS AMY
TONGUE AND THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY.
AND JOINING ME IS THE CHIEF
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER MILES
BURNETT AND THE IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME I KNOW IT'S BEEN A LONG
DAY FOR YOU I WOULD JUST
PROPOSES QUESTIONS THAT ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS SPECIFICALLY.
TO THE BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL
REGARDING THE SECURITY
OPERATIONS CENTER.
I WAS REALLY FAST THAT WAS VERY.
I WAS EXPECTING A LITTLE LONGER
BUT THANK YOU THANKS FOR THE
BREVITY IT'S APPRECIATED.
NO COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
GREAT.
AT THIS POINT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN SO MY
APOLOGIES WILL PROBABLY PUT IT
ON A POTENTIALLY THERE VOTE ONLY
OR OR HAVE YOU COME BACK AT SOME
POINT BUT OF GIVEN THAT WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH.
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM TO VOTE
OKAY SO -- LA YOU KNOW CONCERNS
FINANCE NO CONCERNS ANY PUBLIC
COMMENTS.
NOPE.
OKAY LET'S GO TO WE'RE GONNA
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN ALL RIGHT --
NEXT PROJECT APPROVAL CYCLE.
RIGHT IT WILL BE A NOTHING MY
CUP OF JOINING ME WOULD BE THE
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF FIVE
CALIFORNIA -- PRIOR TO DELIVERY.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBER.
MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
AFTERNOON RATHER MY NAME IS
ANDREA SPEARS AND I AM THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OVER THE OFFICE
OF STATEWIDE PROJECT DELIVERY
WITH THAT CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY.
AND I'M VERY HAPPY TO BE HERE TO
BE ABLE TO TALK TO YOU A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE PART OF THE LIFE
CYCLE PLANNING PROCESS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO HEAR A LITTLE
BIT OF BACKGROUND ABOUT THAT
PROCESS OR WOULD YOU PREFER IF
YOU WANT TO KEEP IT VERY BRIEF I
ABSOLUTELY WILL VERY FREE HE
LIKES. TO TWO MINUTES ABSOLUTELY
GREAT -- THE THE PROJECT
APPROVAL LIFE CYCLE IS A IS A
PLANNING PROCESS FOR PROJECTS IT
WAS DEVELOPED IN TWO THOUSAND
AND SIXTEEN WITH THE GOAL TO
HELP DEPARTMENTS TO REALLY JUST
TO DO BETTER PLANNING -- IT
PLACES GREATER EMPHASIS ON
PLANNING QUALITY.
IT SEEKS TO REDUCE RISK.
AS DEPARTMENTS ARE PLANNING
THEIR PROJECTS AND IT PLACES A
LOT OF FOCUS ON THE DELIVERY OF
VALUE FOR PROJECTS. TO ESTABLISH
A SOLID FOUNDATION UPON WHICH
PROJECTS CAN BE EXECUTED SO THIS
IS REALLY ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
YOU KNOW -- DEPARTMENTS ARE NOT
JUST CHECKING OFF BOXES WHEN
THEY'RE DOING PLANNING WITH A
PAPER PROCESS THAT THEY'RE
DEVOTING THEIR TIME TO HAVING A
GOOD PLAN SO THAT HAVE A GOOD
PROJECT DOT COM.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT VERY
MUCH YOU'RE WELCOME ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NO.
FINANCE AND ALEJO.
SURE PRIME MINSTER LA ALL TRY TO
KEEP THIS SHORT -- SO THIS --
PROCESS WAS SOMETHING THAT WE
WROTE IT BUDGET AND POLICY POSTS
ABOUT RELATED TO THE ALIGNMENT
OF THIS PROCESS WITH THE BUDGET
PROCESS -- WE HIGHLIGHTED THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET INCLUDES
FUNDING REQUESTS FOR AT LEAST
THREE IT PROJECTS -- THAT HAVE
COMPLETED THE PAL PROCESS BUT
THAT THERE ARE SEVEN OTHERS --
THAT ARE REQUESTING FUNDING
THROUGH THE BUDGET THAT HAVE NOT
COMPLETED THE PROCESS AND IT'S
ABOUT A HUNDRED FIFTEEN MILLION
OVER THREE FISCAL YEARS -- WE DO
KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME DRIVERS
OF THIS MISALIGNMENT WHERE
PROJECTS ARE REQUESTING FUNDING
IN ADVANCE OF COMPLETING THE POP
PROCESS -- NOTABLY THE LENGTH
AND TIMING OF THIS PROCESS
LEGISLATIVELY MANDATED DEADLINES
AS WELL AS THE APPROACH O
IMPLEMENTING THE PROJECT SO --
THE AGILE APPROACH THAT WE'VE
BEEN DISCUSSING THROUGHOUT THE
HEARING -- ONE OF THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS IS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS BEING ASTON AND
SEVERAL OF THESE CASES TO
APPROVE PROJECT FUNDING WITH
HAVING LIMITED INFORMATION ON
THE ACTUAL COST SCHEDULE AND
SCOPE OF THE PROJECT -- AND THAT
THE FIRM BASE LINE FOR THOSE
WILL BE DETERMINED AT THE END OF
THIS PROCESS AND SO -- WE BASS
OF THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER
REQUIRING CDT AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO ADDRESS THIS
MISALIGNMENT AND ITS CAUSES --
INCLUDING PROVIDING THE
LEGISLATURE WITH A LIST OF
POTENTIAL CHANGES TO THE PROCESS
WE WOULD NOTE THAT WE HAVE BEEN
IN COMMUNICATION WITH CITY T.
AND THEY ARE OFFERING A A
MEETING WITH US NEXT WEEK TO
DISCUSS THIS SO -- THINGS ARE
MOVING -- BUT AND WE WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IN EACH
OF THE RESPECTIVE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE THIS ISSUES BEING
ADDRESSED AS WELL SO WITHOUT A
LEAVE IT THERE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GREAT.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS.
NO WELL THANKS TO ALL OF YOU FOR
THIS ITEM IS ALSO GOING TO BE
HELD OPEN THIS WAS ALREADY
SLATED TO BE HELD OPEN.
THANK YOU ALL FOR A FOR STAYING
WITH US UP UNTIL THE END.
THIS MEETING [inaudible]
IS ADJOURNED